The joe rogan experience
podcast all day.
[inaudible]
Mr. Russell.
Hey,
thank you very much for doing this,
man.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
It's a,
we were saying right before the podcast got started.
It's always a weird thing when,
when people sit down,
it's like you don't want to talk too much because there's so much to say on the
air.
You don't want to get it out before they get to air.
But I was saying that it's very,
it's appropriate having you on today because we're just now going to war with
Syria.
Right.
And uh,
we were,
uh,
we were just talking about how bizarre this isis thing is and how it's just
American people said,
you know,
we don't want to go to war with Syria.
It was this big thing and Obama was on television.
Everybody just openly rejected it.
Left and right.
It was pretty much the American public was like,
we're done with war.
Like we want to get out of Afghanistan.
We don't want this Iraq thing anymore.
We don't want to go to Syria.
And so everything just sort of calmed down and then all of a sudden the isis
rose up from the,
from the ashes.
And this isis thing I did with different names.
Isis,
I,
I've seen it.
Isi L,
right?
Yeah.
And um,
I was saying,
I don't like to get conspiracy oriented because it's so easy to do.
But if you wanted to,
you would say,
well,
this is obviously they've come up with a mechanism to get us into Syria.
Sure.
I mean,
so there's two kinds of conspiracies.
There's an open conspiracy and then there's a closed conspiracy.
Right?
So I think this is sort of an open conspiracy.
A lot of people are saying both left and right by the way,
that isis was really a creation of American foreign policy.
Not that there were a bunch of dudes sitting in a room in the White House with
cigars and saying,
hey,
we need to create this monster in order to sort of impose American,
we'll abroad.
But that through many,
many conscious decisions over many years in the Middle East through direct
interventions,
militarily and otherwise,
they created the conditions for this bunch of psychopathic 20 year olds with
RPGs and swords beheading people,
right?
So,
you know,
creating a vacuum in Iraq,
right?
By going to war there,
by removing the dictator who was at least holding control over the people and
where people like this,
a funding the rebels in Syria.
And also more importantly,
a lot of people miss this.
You know,
what's one of the things that's been happening if you look at it just from a
material standpoint over the last 12 years at least,
is that the United States has been flooding that area with weapons,
right?
So,
and if you look at it,
there's a great piece,
I think it was in the Guardian a few weeks ago.
Uh,
the Isis is using American made weapons,
right?
That have been coming into that region,
mostly into Iraq,
but elsewhere for just decades.
Right?
So it's just,
it creates this,
it creates a situation where,
uh,
sort of a self fulfilling prophecy,
sort of an Obgyn,
open conspiracy,
because you certainly say that American foreign policy makers and all of them
really.
And that's Bush and that's Obama and that's all of them really want to have an
American presence,
a military strong military presence around the world.
And in particular in the Middle East where all the oil is.
So,
you know,
it's not it,
I'm not saying it was deliberate that they,
it wasn't a deliberate choice to create this beast that's called Isis,
but it's certainly serves their purposes.
And it seems like if you,
I mean if you look at the entire situation in the Middle East,
it seems like there's no good way to just get out of there.
It seems like,
is there,
I mean,
please tell me,
I mean there's a way to,
yeah,
I mean,
so I'm an out now guy.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that was the answer in Vietnam,
right?
That's what they,
that's what the Anti Vietnam war called for for many,
many years was out.
Now,
not,
not a gradual withdrawal,
which is what the politicians called for backup,
because that's the quote responsible thing to do,
but out now,
and I think history proves that was the correct answer to that,
right?
I think that if the United States had left immediately in 1964 65 name a year
name a time,
it would have been a better thing for everyone.
Now,
communism would have,
the communist would have taken control of Vietnam,
but they did anyway,
right?
And so what we had was instead of about 2 million people,
mostly civilians die,
right?
We would have had far fewer,
we would have had the same outcome essentially with far fewer.
And then also,
and we've got to talk about blowback,
right?
So,
you know,
the,
the carpet bombing of not just Vietnam,
but several countries during that war caused untold numbers of people to hate
our fucking guts,
right?
America's guts and that,
you know,
uh,
that's blowback,
right?
They didn't come and fly airplanes into our buildings,
but you know,
it was anti American in many ways.
And it also served.
And here's very important thing.
It's served the interests of the cod damn communists,
right?
Because it's because the communist could say,
look at these barbarians coming here and killing our children and women,
right?
You should support us.
We will protect you from them.
So it actually played into the hands of the Communist.
And the very same thing is happening and it has been happening in the Middle
East for many,
many years.
David Petraeus of all people said before the Senate about three years ago,
he said,
US funding of Israel in particular us funding of all these corrupt regimes in
the,
in the Middle East,
and our interventions is the number one recruiting tool for al Qaeda,
right?
And it's the number one recruiting tool for isis.
They say,
look,
here's these infidels who have been invading us and killing our people and
taking control of our resources for decades,
right?
We will,
we will fight back for you.
Right?
And so it,
it's,
it's uh,
it becomes a self fulfilling prophecy if you want to maintain a presence there,
which they do.
The United States does.
You keep creating your own enemies to fight against.
It's perpetual.
So what could beat,
is there anything that can be done to mitigate the disastrous effects of us
pulling out and creating this power vacuum?
Is there anything that can be done?
I mean,
once we're already there,
we can't go back in time.
We can't stop the Iraq invasion.
It would be nice if we could pretty much,
no one thinks it's a good idea now,
today in hindsight,
everyone thinks it was a terrible idea.
The only good that came out of it was getting Saddam Hussein out,
getting rid of his psychopathic sons.
But now look at all the shit you have there and you have a million people dead,
right?
So the anti intervention,
it's argument is simply that pretty much every interview intervention has a
negative consequence.
So the less the better.
Right?
So my position is that do none,
right?
But when you have a guy like a Hitler or someone along those lines that's
causing genocide and planning to take over the world.
And
so,
but,
uh,
so,
so for Hitler,
right,
there's a large stream of thought among historians,
very respectable stream of thought that the Nazis rose to power out of
conditions created by the allies after World War One.
So that,
you know,
extracting all these resources through forced payments from the Germans as
reparations after World War One,
a really laid the groundwork for the rise of this,
this totalitarian who said,
hey,
look what those westerners did to us.
They decimated this country.
They shamed us,
they brought us into shame and degradation.
We need a strong,
powerful leader.
We need discipline.
We need order.
We need to get rid of these foreign influences like Jews who were considered to
be foreign,
right?
In essence,
because they were a nation,
unless people,
uh,
and the communists who had allegiance to know state,
right?
Um,
and so many people have argued,
not just wacko conspiracy theorists that,
that it was actually American and western foreign policy in the early 20th
century that really made the rise of Nazi is impossible.
Like that's the greatest,
possibly the greatest example of blowback in human history.
That's a crazy example of blowback.
It's,
it seems like it's a perpetual cycle then it seems like everything we've ever
done in the past has led us to do more things in the future to combat the blow
back from the things we've done in the past.
Yeah.
So I mean,
if you look at it,
but if you look at the history of foreign policy,
and by the way,
that's the book I'm working on now.
Uh,
so this is a very appropriate topic for me.
Um,
you know,
you will see beginning really even in the early 90 [inaudible] in the early 18th
century,
uh,
with,
or not,
sorry,
late 18th century,
but some of the founding fathers,
but certainly through the 19th century and certainly through the 20th century,
one continuous thread among policy makers,
which is we must change the world in our image,
right?
I mean,
that's been bipartisan.
It's been the left.
It's been the right,
it's been,
I mean,
the Liberals and the conservatives,
it's been the Democrats and the Republicans for centuries now.
We must have America abroad now.
Not everyone agreed with that.
There were people in the Senate who were sort of isolationists or anti
interventionists,
but that's been a pretty,
there's been a near consensus among American politicians for about two centuries
that we should expand what is great about America.
And unfortunately that has meant killing a lot of people.
That's what everyone's terrified of with the Islamic state,
is that
they want to impose sharia law throughout the rest of the world.
I mean,
that's what everyone's afraid of the,
the,
the religion of America.
They,
uh,
you know,
what we subscribe to versus the religion of Sharia law.
So I have an answer for that.
Okay.
Yeah.
So good luck motherfuckers imposing sharia law on the whole world.
Right.
And so what my,
a lot of what my work is on now,
and I'm not the only one who's done this,
is to look at what's actually going on.
You know,
in places like Ron and in places like Riyadh and in places like Cairo,
um,
what are the,
what are sort of ordinary folks,
Iranians and Egyptians and Saudis actually doing all day long.
And you can figure it out really quickly by simply looking at the skyline in
those cities.
And what you'll see is you'll see these big apartment buildings.
He's big cinder block apartment buildings.
And on top of those,
center on top of those apartment buildings are dozens,
sometimes hundreds of satellite dishes,
which are streaming in Fox,
the Simpsons porn like you wouldn't believe during the porn.
They love porn in Middle East and Pakistan,
Google did,
Google has announced for several years,
Pakistan is the leading country in the world for searches for the word sex.
Whoa.
And then in particular,
uh,
also interesting,
searches for gay sex,
like terms like gay sex terms like anal sex and men,
men,
men on men or whatever.
The Middle East is like leading the world in that,
right?
And they,
what they love is they love American nasty pop culture and Western nasty pop
culture.
They love,
they love women in Bikinis and they love whiskey and they love stupid,
you know,
they love Jersey shore and the rest of it stuff that we looked down on and
actually what it's doing,
my argument is,
is that it's subverting the hell at a Sharia law every single day.
We say we look down on it,
but we obviously created support it and probably consume more of it than it.
When I say,
when I say we,
I mean up to you and no,
I know.
I mean uptight professors like the ones I deal with,
not like normal people.
You've been fired from being like a little too controversial.
Yeah.
I read an article about you Huffington posts that you wrote.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What,
what,
what was that all about?
Well,
I mean,
um,
so I,
uh,
you know,
I was trained at Columbia University and got my phd there in American history
and uh,
sort of found that like,
um,
historians in general,
but in particular the historians I was being trained by,
you know,
they consider themselves to be left wing and radical.
But then there,
there's a real limitation on that.
And one of the limitations was that they had a real disdain for what normal
people do all day long,
like what they're doing in Riyadh in Tiran.
Uh,
they had a real disdain for sorted the,
the normal activities of working class ordinary folks.
Like they thought that what people watched on TV was retarded and should not be
studied and shouldn't,
they shouldn't be doing it.
Um,
that it wasn't,
that's not real history.
That's not what's really going on.
What you should be studying the Senate and you should be studying sort of
economics.
And she was gonna be studying foreign policy.
And what I found was,
you know,
first of all,
that's what,
of course most Americans do as they consume that kind of stuff,
much more than they do political speeches.
Right?
And more importantly,
kind of in that popular culture and in particular the stuff that we most look
down on,
what you'll find is stuff like sex and freedom and drugs and drinking and
freedom and people doing what they want to do sort of opposed to an against kind
of our puritan tradition,
right?
So that America has always been split between its puritanism,
which is really powerful still up in particular in our formal culture like in
politics and what they tell us in schools,
right?
And and,
and hedonism,
which is what we get in popular culture,
right?
So it's as we were this very weird schizophrenia culture,
There's this conflict between the two.
And what I found was that people who call themselves left wing and radical are
actually really wedded to the puritanical side that they,
they're really about people being disciplined and controlled and working hard
and the work ethic and all that stuff.
And I know you,
you've talked about,
I've heard you talk about the work ethic on here and elsewhere,
but we can get into what that actually means because there's also confusion
about what that means.
But I was sort of frustrated.
I was like,
first of all,
Yo,
I'm walking the streets in New York City when we went to Columbia and I,
nobody looks like these people in my history books,
including Rosa Parks who's on your wall here and Martin Luther King who a lot,
and we can talk about this.
This is a big part of my book.
A lot.
Those people were extremely conservative,
culturally,
extremely conservative culturally and looked down upon and scolded black people
for black culture,
for things like jazz and rock and roll.
Martin Luther King was opposed to rock and roll called it the devil's music.
People don't know this.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so I started looking at that.
I started looking at these new heroes and the new social history,
you know,
these left wing activists and people like Rosa Parks,
Martin Luther King and feminists suffragists and all that.
And I found it like they actually agreed with the puritans about things like sex
and work,
that sex is terrible and work is awesome and virtuous.
So I got very frustrated.
I started writing my lectures and my classes at Barnard College,
which is the women's college affiliated with Columbia.
I started looking at American history.
Through that Lens.
I started looking at American history through the lens of this conflict,
this eternal conflict between discipline and order and community and nation on
one hand and puritanism and on the other hand,
popular culture and sex and freedom and desire.
And I found this whole new way of telling the story.
And I found all these people on one side sorta just behaving on their own,
doing the things they wanted to do,
that we're violating these puritanical principles.
People like prostitutes,
people like drunks,
people like criminals,
people like gays,
people like slaves who were dancing when you weren't supposed to dance.
And on the other hand,
all these guardians of the moral order who weren't just the founding fathers,
uh,
and the generals and the inventors,
but it was people like abolitionists who were opposed to slavery,
but they were opposed to slavery for funky reasons.
We can talk about,
uh,
and suffragists.
He wanted women to be really just as upstanding as men and to not drink and not
have sex,
et cetera.
Um,
and so I gave lectures.
I was given the,
uh,
introduction to American history course at Columbia.
They did because they didn't know what I was up to.
And because it's a weird thing,
it's one of the strangest industries.
There's no oversight over what you're doing and your classrooms,
no one ever comes and watches what you say.
It's a very strange thing in higher education professors,
99% of the time just go into the classroom and their colleagues have no idea
what they're saying.
Does that become an issue with ego?
Because a,
I find that anytime when you get one person that gets to communicate to a large
group of people and they have to listen to you,
especially if parts of their future rely upon you.
Like they're your grades,
your,
your GPA,
it's important to pass this class.
And so this person has this position of power and influence.
It's very unusual.
Sure.
Because of that.
A lot of times people,
they,
that they get into that position of being a professor,
they push their ideology in a very rigid and inflexible way.
I'm right,
you are wrong.
I am older.
You are younger.
I am smart.
You are dumb.
Absolutely.
And it's the time gross apps.
I agree.
So what I have to say about that is that we all,
we all come at questions through our own ideologies,
right?
No one,
there's nothing.
I don't think there's any such thing as an objective history or an objective
political science.
I mean,
I think we all talk about these things through our own biases and our own
lenses,
right?
First of all,
I think what we should do is just admit it and be honest about it.
And that's what I tried to do in my classes.
I try to say,
Hey,
you know what I just told you?
That's my interpretation.
That's not the truth.
I never tell the truth.
I only tell people what I think.
Right.
And with an argument.
Right,
right.
Um,
and the second thing is,
and this is what the,
this is the real problem.
I think in higher education,
which makes me,
it makes me crazy every single day,
is that right now,
higher ed in particular in the social sciences and humanities is on locked down
by the academic left.
Okay.
And I come out of the left and I'm left wing.
And a lot of ways,
and in some ways I'm not,
but what I hate is that there's just almost no variety of discourse on college
campuses that pretty much it.
And if there's been studies done,
I mean like 95% of English and history professors voted for Obama.
Right?
I mean that tells you right there that there's not a whole lot of debate going
on.
Why do you think that is?
Why?
Why is academia and the left sort of inexorably connected?
Yeah.
Well,
so when a lot of left academics are asked this,
the answer that they give you is we're smarter,
right?
Right.
So that we,
it's just in tiff,
you're intelligent and study,
you will come to that position.
Now I said it because the right is kinda inexorably connected to religion
because Christianity and the right are pretty much inseparable.
Well,
even even libertarians
who are atheists get run out of the house,
you can't get a job as a libertarian.
Wow.
Um,
no,
I mean,
so it's,
it's all historical,
right?
So if you look at the history of higher education,
and a lot of people forget this,
you know,
uh,
higher education in this country is only about two centuries old.
And as a,
as a major mass institution,
I mean,
uh,
the right,
right wing conservatives controlled the joint until the 1960s.
Right?
So what was being taught at Harvard and Yale and Princeton and cal and UCLA was
things like capitalism is awesome and black people are inferior and women should
be in the home.
I mean,
it was,
conservatives had that whole place on lockdown.
Uh,
there was a monoculture on,
on the campuses.
Then we'll comes along is the 1960s and all those movements,
all those social movements of the antiwar movement,
the civil rights movement,
feminist movement,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And what happened was those people,
because their movements either sort of succeeded and they considered,
were considered to be done or they couldn't succeed,
they couldn't really create a radical revolution,
the kind that they wanted,
the only place they found that they could go and have a job was colleges as
professors.
So they on Mohs though that generation,
the new left of the 1960s went into graduate school and they all became
professors.
And that's who's been basically teaching college for the last 50 years.
Um,
so I'm,
I'm of the generation that was trained by them.
And so there,
there's some changes going on,
but basically most,
even most people my age,
I'm in my forties but in my generation,
most of us are still sort of influenced by that generation.
So it was this very concerted,
not a conspiracy,
but it was a pretty deliberate attempt in some ways it was conscious to take
over the university that that was the,
that was the only place we could have this radical discourse and get paid for it
and have a career.
Right.
And influenced the,
and influenced the U,
which is one of the things that drives a lot of parents crazy.
The parents that have different ideologies and the kid off to school and the kid
comes back with like some really sure,
you know,
white privilege,
male privilege.
I'm a victim,
lefty talk.
I'm a victim.
Stuff is strong and it's very disempowering.
Oh yeah.
It's confusing too because I don't know if you know this case.
Um,
there's uh,
from Occidental College,
Boston and all universities.
That's where I teach man.
Is that what you did?
Yeah.
Occidental College.
Oh,
down the road.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Do you know the story about the,
uh,
the two young kids,
they were freshmen.
There was onto the hazing thing.
They both get drunk.
Yes.
And they have sex and the guy gets expelled.
They're both sexual assault.
They're both drunk.
Not only they both drunk,
but the girl texts her friend,
I'm about to go have sex.
Text him.
Do you have a condom?
He says,
yes.
get over there.
She says,
I'm on my way.
She goes over there and they decide that it's sexual assault because the girl
had been drinking,
even though the guy had also been drinking.
It's sexual assault.
The guy gets kicked out of college.
He's in the middle of a,
I mean in,
when you're 18 years old,
your life is Sarone into a turmoil.
I mean,
he's kicked out of school for having sex while drunk with a girl who was sex
while drunk.
So you're about to get me fired again again.
Yeah.
Thanks for this.
Thanks man.
Please pick out.
Yeah,
no,
I gotcha.
So this,
this sexual assault either depending on your point of view,
epidemic or hysteria,
the epicenter of it has been occidental or I've taught,
uh,
it started about two years ago.
This is a long conversation to have.
Please.
I think it's an important one because it's confusing as hell.
Okay.
So what happened was in 2010 or 2011,
the United States Department of Education sent a letter to every university and
college in the country that receives federal aid of some kind,
which is basically all of them,
right?
Because of student loans.
Those are backed by the federal government and said,
if you,
if you want to continue receiving federal aid for your students,
you must adjudicate every case,
every accusation,
every accusation of sexual assault on your campus among students.
Okay.
Which means you have to have like basically a tribunal,
uh,
of staff and maybe students,
but usually it's staff and faculty,
right?
So it's a panel of like three or four English professors and the dean of
students and the facilities guy or whoever,
maybe some students asking,
you know,
uh,
adjudicating this case.
So the woman says,
uh,
well,
we were both drunk and whatever,
she tells her story and he tells his story and says,
I absolutely did not rape him.
She says he absolutely did rape me because there's no witnesses almost ever in
these cases.
Right?
What,
what can they then do to decide who's responsible here?
Or is there someone who's responsible?
And what they do is,
and I've talked to people who have been on these boards,
the only thing you can do is ask about their sexual histories.
So you have,
you have English professors asking 19 year olds how many times they've had sex
in the last year,
what kinds of sex with whom,
how did they feel about it?
And then asking the guy the same things,
right?
And then from that information,
and usually it's only that because that's all you got in most cases,
right?
With acquaintance rape,
it's two people in a,
in a room,
a dark room,
and then with the door closed,
almost always there's no evidence,
right?
There's no physical evidence,
no witnesses usually from that they determine responsibility.
Um,
so that's basically what happened in this case.
Uh,
it's,
and the other thing that's,
so that's a nightmare and a lot of ways,
right?
I mean,
talk about seeking justice,
right?
It's very bizarre also that this idea has come out of what a lot of people
believe to be what you would call feminism and what feminism is supposed to push
for as equality,
but not equality when it comes to responsibility for your sexual actions while
you're intoxicated.
Right.
So one of the things that's been infuriating for a lot of people and a lot of
feminists by the way,
is that,
you know,
in response to an uh,
acquaintance rape definitely fucking happens.
You know,
no question about it.
We know people,
I know people very closely what's happening
through the alley that we should also say that getting someone drunk and fucking
them cause you know,
they're drunk is gross.
It is rape.
Sure.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
or at least getting them loaded to the point where they can't figure out what
the fuck is going on.
Right.
So one of the,
one of one answer that's been proffered by many people,
many feminists including has been to say,
Hey,
don't get blackout drunk at the Frat House on Friday night to women.
Right.
And that has been called victim blaming.
Okay.
So you know about this,
right?
So right now,
if you were to leave it at that,
right?
Say That is the sole answer to this problem.
You know,
tell women not to get drunk at a frat house on Friday night.
Maybe that is victim blaming,
but that's not what any of us are saying.
Right.
Well that's like saying,
don't the Rutgers kid that got killed by a bear two days ago don't run from
bear.
Exactly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Does that victim blaming it's fucking wise advice.
If you want to survive a bear attack,
don't run.
They chase.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't have a daughter,
but I have a son,
but you know,
if I had a daughter,
goddamn right,
I'm going to tell her not to get blackout drunk at the Frat House.
Yeah.
You know,
you're going to try to stop me and tell me that's,
that's blaming my daughter.
Um,
I don't think guys should get blackout drunk at the Frat House.
Sure.
Yeah.
Right.
It's not good for you.
People fall off of roofs at frat houses and die from it.
Yeah.
There are people that will take advantage of you and not just sexually.
They'll sure.
There's vicious people that will do things to you if they think you're passed
out.
Absolutely.
It's just not smart.
Yeah.
So feminism,
um,
this particular brand of it,
one of the things that's not talked about much,
and I tried to talk about this,
is that it,
uh,
it takes agency away from women,
right?
So it's like,
it's,
it's basically saying that women are helpless before these rapists.
You know,
and what we,
all we can do is more allies against the rapists and tell them they're bad.
Now many of those feminists have agreed that it's a very,
very tiny percentage of men who are rapists and that most rapes are committed by
something like 4% of men or something like that,
or less than 4%.
Um,
so getting into,
you're gonna tell those guys the serial rapists,
most of them are serial rapists,
that they're bad and they shouldn't rape
the fact that it's not going to be less,
even if it's one person,
they could have a hundred guys.
No,
no,
no.
Sorry.
It's,
it's of,
of the rapes committed for,
uh,
what is it?
It's 4%,
4% of the rape.
I don't know.
It's something like that
really hard.
It's a very tiny percentage.
It's really hard to do statistics with rape too,
because a lot of people don't report rape and they're embarrassed and ashamed.
And
we do have,
well,
uh,
the bureau of Justice Department of Justice has conducted a pretty massive
surveys of women.
So this is not reported crimes.
This is just,
they went in and ask women questions about their history with assault.
And there's been this massive decline and rapes and sexual
assaults since the 1990s,
like more than 60% decline.
So also the talk of a rape epidemic,
um,
and a rape culture now I think is overblown.
I mean,
of course there are elements in our culture that are definitely rape cultures,
right?
I mean,
there's no doubt,
you know,
there's a little corners here and there,
but the dominant culture is not a rape culture.
Right.
My issue is that the people that are crying out for this,
especially the men,
they,
there's so,
it's so suspect,
it's so white nightie but the whole thing about it,
it's these really emo feminist men who just look like they're just clamoring for
female acceptance and love and appreciation.
And they're just going way out of their way to talk about this.
And I can understand if this is a personal issue,
I can understand that anybody would be concerned that a human being would take
advantage of another human being.
But to make it your primary concern,
to make it like this,
I was thinking you focus in constant concentrate on,
on a regular basis all the time.
It's like a almost like a rape fetish,
rape or victimization fetish.
And this,
this apologizing.
Do you remember that video that came out?
A dear women?
It was one of the most horrific videos ever.
It was widely mocked,
but it was these like really fucked up socially retarded men who have made this
video where they were apologizing for all the things that women had to endure
for men.
But these guys were just creepy.
Fucking weird.
I was like undone.
You've never seen this.
I've got to play it for okay.
Cause it's beautiful.
It's beautiful and it's ridiculous.
So yeah.
So,
but here's the thing about that,
you know,
it's like the,
the mess.
The other message in that is that it's for men to save women,
right?
Exactly.
Excuse me,
feminists.
Feminism was about women liberating themselves,
right?
We can't do it for them.
We cannot do it for them.
Right?
So talking to men,
talking to those serial rapists about how bad they are and how bad this is,
what exactly is that going to accomplish?
A and B,
it's putting,
it's putting the responsibility on men and it's saying women must be saved,
which is like that is the soul of conservatism,
right?
To say that we must come save this,
our social inferiors that is like the essence of old school patriarchy and
conservatism.
It is to meet antifeminist to the bone and that's what no one is talking about
this.
Well,
this idea that the women can't consent because they've had a couple of drinks.
Is,
is a weird issue because there's clearly,
there's a scale,
there's a couple drinks where you're getting silly and you do you do you mean
you might fuck somebody's in a regretful way,
like say,
oh,
I shouldn't have slept with that guy,
but it's not rape,
but they want to call that rape.
But then there's blackout drunk,
which is right.
Sure.
And somewhere along the line it becomes reprehensible.
Absolutely.
It's three drinks in or four drinks in me.
Could,
it's debatable.
Sure.
Um,
do you know the bill and the,
in the California legislature?
That's about to be the law of the land is most likely no.
So yeah,
they're gonna there.
It's probably going to pass.
Um,
so that it's applied to all state schools in California,
um,
in which defines sexual assault and rape.
Uh,
in many ways that completely put all of us in the category of rapist because it
includes,
it includes having sex with someone when they're intoxicated.
Anyone.
Yeah.
So your girlfriend,
boyfriend,
girlfriend,
have a couple of drinks and laughing and giggling and they make out they have
sex.
Yeah.
And they don't even,
they don't even put a,
um,
a sort of a threshold on how many drinks it takes.
So I'm,
you know,
senior,
I'm a serial rapist according to this.
Like we all are.
Yeah.
And what his intoxication,
there's intoxication.
That's the limit of alcohol intoxication when you're driving,
which a lot of people were debating is too low that that would be legally
applied to sex.
Right.
So there's another thing that's very easy.
One of the things I do is I sort of tried to expose how conservative a lot of
the left is because they don't even don't even realize it.
This is,
this is really conservative,
right?
So it's like,
it's micromanaging our sex lives.
Um,
and you know,
it's saying that sex,
that the state must come in and protect us from each other and it must,
the state must come in or the college administration must protect women from
these,
from Saks,
well from demons and the demons are the nails,
the nails,
but not just demons from sex itself.
Like sex is seen as this sort of dangerous,
harmful thing.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of set apart from everything else in the war
all especially then if you say,
even if you,
it's consensual and you're conscious and you're awake and you enjoy it and you
have fun.
If you're in town,
it is rape.
Yeah,
the con,
that's why that,
because it's sad.
That case in Occidental that you raised,
I mean,
so they say,
and I've read the whole report,
okay.
By the college,
the report says by the College,
this was consensual sex.
Okay.
Period.
And when I read that,
I said,
okay,
case closed.
Then I read that he gets expelled because they were both drunk.
Eh.
You know,
I don't know what to say about that other than this is lunacy and it's,
it's,
but it's also,
it's deeply conservative and right.
But he's also deeply sexist.
[inaudible] how's the guy get expelled and the girl does and deeply sexist.
Exactly.
Right.
That's sexist.
I agree.
It's crazy.
I mean,
no,
look,
no one got hurt.
There were kids that liked each other.
They were attracted to each other and they had sex.
They were communicating with each other back and forth through text.
It wasn't like she didn't like this guy.
It wasn't like,
yeah,
she was most certainly drunk.
But she also was saying,
nor friend,
I'm going to go have sex with this guy.
Right.
The fact that that's not an open and shut case,
it exposes the lunacy of this ideology that exposed to the,
the vast majority of intelligent adult Americans.
They would just,
they would put their foot down and go,
wait,
what the fuck did you just say?
What's going on?
I totally agree.
This is a bubble.
This ideologies is weird.
It is a bubble.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean,
it's,
I think it's mostly
hysteria.
Um,
however,
look,
you know why we agree,
you know,
rape happens.
Yeah.
Acquaintance rape happens.
Yes.
Husbands,
rape wives,
boyfriends,
rape girlfriends all the time,
right?
It's very,
it's friends,
right?
Boyfriend,
boyfriends or people,
oh,
well you want to talk about prison?
So you know that men get raped more often than women in this culture,
but the rate by men.
So it's really,
it's kind of a moot point.
How's that shows?
Men are pieces of shit each other.
Well,
sure.
When there's no women to rape,
we just rape the rape rates in prison are absolutely horrifying and
underreported.
Yeah,
no,
but so what do we do about it?
Right?
And so here's the,
here's sort of the intrinsic problem with rape and especially acquaintance rape.
There's very rarely any evidence,
there's very rarely eye witnesses.
There's very rarely physical evidence.
Even if there is physical evidence,
you can't prove that that bruise proves that this guy raped.
Right?
So what do you do?
It's a tough question and I understand that that's what people are kind of
trying to struggle with and are trying to come up with these new what devices to
stop it from happening.
I think the devices that are coming up with are terrible,
but what do we do?
And you know,
um,
so one thing,
I mean,
you got to keep working on the criminal justice system.
You got to get cops to like processed those rape kits more efficiently,
which they're not doing in many states.
There's a lot of rape kits that are sitting on shelves that have never been
processed.
And you've got to make,
you know,
cops just better at this,
which is what feminists have been doing.
My mother in the 1960s,
that was one of the things she did as a feminist in Berkeley.
She,
she pushed hard.
She protested against the police force in the bay area at police forces in the
bay area to take rape seriously,
which cops didn't do for forever until then.
So do,
that's one thing.
And the other thing is
you'll like this.
I mean,
I,
I've been,
I say Jujitsu man.
Seriously.
I mean like,
and the inability to throw an elbow,
I mean,
and there's a group called insight,
which is women,
women of color against violence who have been doing this.
They have,
they have martial arts classes,
they have martial arts schools.
They organize together and they kicked the shit out of men who tried to attack
them.
Um,
now that's not the ultimate answer.
That's not gonna.
That's not going to get rid of all rapists,
but at least partial solution leave.
You believe me,
if I had a daughter,
I'd be telling her to do that.
Yeah.
I do have daughters.
I teach.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's,
it's one of those weird subjects to where if you discuss it,
you become a rape apologist.
You become,
I mean,
you're not even allowed to deviate from the ideology if you deviate from it in
any way,
shape or form.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's a very strict dogma.
Yeah.
I mean you,
this is non consensual because she can't consent because she's had a drink.
Even if the guy has,
I've even seen it written that lady's like,
Oh,
a feminist wrote this blog saying women don't have sex with your man if he's
drunk because he can't consent,
which is the most ridiculous shit ever.
I mean,
it's just the whole idea being that sex is eve.
Exactly.
And that's,
that's really what it comes down to.
You're not talking about people getting hurt if they decided to get and wrestle.
Yeah.
I mean,
is that assault right?
What is that?
If they both decide,
you know,
if a guy and a girl,
take martial arts together and the guy,
you know,
uh,
in the girl or drinking and the girl wants a wrestle,
is she not allowed to consent that she actually wants to wrestle because she's
been drinking.
It's only applied to sexuality.
It's not applied to driving.
If you're driving under the influence,
you are absolutely,
totally responsible.
If you're smashed,
no one says,
hey,
she couldn't consent to driving because she was drunk.
You're,
you're responsible for your actions entirely except sexually.
Yup.
This comes back to what I started talking about,
which is the cultural roots of our country,
which is puritanism so right.
I mean,
if you look at Puritans,
people in Plymouth Rock,
you know,
that's one of the things they talked about Ad Nauseum,
that sex is the devil's work,
that it is this special thing that is evil and harmful and damaging and must be
controlled more than anything else.
And that is run through our culture in various ways to the very present.
And I would say that a lot of what's going on in this sexual assault discourse,
stuff that we're talking about,
uh,
you see it there too,
that it's,
that's what's going on.
That there's this belief that,
you know,
if I had sex that I didn't really feel good about with my boyfriend or not,
and we were really drunk and I woke up and I was like,
ah,
don't like this dude.
And this was not okay.
It's like,
I think people are trained to think that they're damaged,
that this is a really terrible thing that happened to them.
Um,
I don't know about that.
I mean,
it's a crazy thing.
And this goes to prostitution.
This is why prostitution is illegal,
right?
It's like we sell our bodies from money all the time.
You know?
That's what massage.
Yeah.
You're selling your body fucking MMA.
Is that intimate,
you know,
is that intimate?
Right?
I mean,
let's Jujitsu as well.
Competition.
Well,
but it's extremely intimate.
They're good analogies.
Massage because massage feels good.
No one wants to do it to you.
You pay them to do it.
And that becomes an occupation is very respected.
Yeah.
You know,
you talked to someone and I'm a massage therapist.
Oh,
that's cool.
Sure.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But there's all sorts of professions where,
you know,
we sell our bodies intimately.
You could even argue that's what we're doing now.
I mean,
you know,
it's like on my body is here are your buddies there?
We're using our minds,
we're talking and this is the,
this is exploiting.
Our body's not going to be a stretch.
Okay.
Sorry.
And I teach when I teach,
I say,
yeah,
right.
I mean,
so I'm like,
I said to my students,
look,
I'm standing here.
I brought my body here.
You're looking at me,
you're judging me.
It's like I'm using my body.
You're getting paid for this.
It's every job.
You're selling your body.
We draw a line of prostitution for some strange reason,
but I don't think it's a strange reason.
I think it's appearance in Harrington and yeah,
man.
I think it's because we believe deep down that sexist special.
Yeah.
In a bad way.
Do you know Molly crab apples?
Yeah,
sure.
Very interesting woman for sex,
sex worker activist and not try to list,
yeah,
sure.
Her,
her,
her take on it as you know,
completely open minded.
She's like,
why?
Why is it bad?
You know?
She's like,
I have friends that are sex.
She goes,
sure.
And it's fine.
Like what did they like it?
They don't mind.
They have clients that they enjoy being with and they get paid for that.
Like,
isn't it better to do that than to do something you don't like and isn't it a
good thing to get sex,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I have,
I've worked with,
and I have friends who are in the sex worker activist sort of movement right
now.
And She's part of it.
I don't know her,
but she's a part of it.
And you know,
the more common argument among them is it's not like we all love it,
right.
What it is for them is it's a job,
right?
It's a job.
And some of us like it,
like some of us,
like our jobs and some of us are don't like it.
Um,
and,
but that's it.
It's just a job for them.
Like porn stars asking,
ask it if you know anything about the porn industry,
the porn stars,
that's how they think of it when they go to work.
It's not like,
Oh hell yeah,
we're going to part.
It's just like,
ah,
okay,
right.
Got To get up at nine o'clock and I go to the set and I'm going to be there for
three hours and we're going to have lunch at noon and then,
you know,
and they'd come home.
Right.
I mean that's every,
every person in the porn industry I've ever known has said this about certainly
would,
it becomes once you do it for a while,
it becomes a job.
Right?
Yeah.
I think you're,
you're onto something.
I definitely think you're on to something when it comes to the puritan roots of
this idea that sex is evil and that kids,
you know,
away from their houses for the first time at 18 years of age having sex in a
dorm room.
Sure.
There's also the thing that happens to where the people that you communicate
with after the fact can tell you what a horrible thing has happened to you.
And they do it with like this rabbit intention.
And that was one of the parts of the story that I found quite fascinating.
Like the friends of the guy versus the friends of the girl,
like what their,
their take on it was and that the girl came over,
she was drunk.
The guy's friend saw her and they'll go,
yeah,
they were both fucked up.
They mean he had drank a half of a bottle of vodka and she drank countless beers
or whatever,
but the girl's friends were like,
what was definitely rape?
It was definitely sexually assault.
Yeah,
well it's even worse than that and now I'm really going to get fired.
One of the things that happens,
and it happened in this case from what we can tell from the evidence is that,
um,
so the average reporting time for sexual assault on campuses is close to a year
after the,
after the alleged assault.
It's hundreds of days.
It's,
it's close to,
it's something at two or 300 a days is the average time it takes people to
report these things.
And we have lots of testimony of those people.
Those women saying,
saying that,
well,
I didn't really,
I didn't know at first what it was.
I didn't feel good about it,
but he didn't know what it was.
And then my professor started talking to me and that's what happened.
In this case we know pretty sure for were sure.
Pretty sure that a particular professor,
they're not only convinced her that it was rape,
but also did a demographic profiling of the guy and said,
well,
he belongs to these particular demographic groups who are likely to be rapists.
Yeah.
What demographic groups or like all that?
That was one of the more amazing things.
He's a member of a team.
I forget.
I think it's either tennis or one of the,
I don't have one of the teams.
It's supposedly more likely to be full of rapist and other God and that he's was
a Valedictorian.
Yeah,
smart.
So He's more likely to be a rape because I guess they have a sense of
entitlement is the idea.
I don't know.
I don't even know what the argument is,
but that was,
it was in the press.
You can look it up.
Oh my God.
Raisie foundation for individual rights and education,
fire,
awesome organization.
Everyone should support it.
They reported that if you look at their website you want so you can see that.
Yeah.
That's terrifying.
Yes.
It could be that boy who's come a Valedictorian because you've struggled through
high school and kicked ass and tried to get great grades and done your work and
studied and under the supervision of your parents and tutors and what have you,
and you were looking forward to having this great career.
And someone has looked at that hard work and said,
oh,
he's most likely a rapist.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's,
it's very damaging.
That's terrifying.
I've read,
I've read many,
many accounts.
I've met many red,
many accounts of these things where it's like hard to call it rape.
It's hard to call it rape.
What do you go to Jamie?
That the article,
Oh,
this is because he was from a good family.
there it is.
Because he was from a good family.
He's more likely in quotes.
Oh my God.
He was a Vac Valedictorian.
He was on a sports team and was from a good family.
So he's monk,
most likely a rapist.
How does someone keep a job when they have that,
that ideology and they promoted to kids.
So this is a colleague of mine,
so I,
I'm,
I'm really kinda constrained here.
But yeah,
it's,
you know what man,
that's a criminal,
that person's terrible person.
If anyone has said that to a young influential kid and that pointed,
this is what's more likely if a person's a rapist.
Did they use force?
Did they drug you?
Did they coerce you?
Did something bad happened to you that makes a person a rapist?
Yes.
Not being from a fucking good family.
All non rapists come from broken homes.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
No I know non rapists got ds.
I think the legal definition is pretty good.
You know,
it's the,
it's the use of force or the threat of the use of force.
Correct.
All those accusations of that professor said to me,
is that pet,
that professor ever come out and confirmed these,
these statements,
her claims at that,
that,
that men like that are more likely to be racist?
Hell no,
of course not.
How could she,
okay,
so this is Jay.
That's,
it's absurd.
Yeah.
It's,
I think,
I don't know what it goes away.
I can only guess where it comes from.
I think that the men at Occidental who have been accused of sexual assault over
the last few years,
I think I'm guessing belong to those categories now.
That's just accusations though.
It's so crazy.
And we're also,
by the way,
talking about,
I don't know,
10 or 20 people.
So that is so fucking crazy.
Yeah.
And it's one of the,
and also,
you know,
one of the,
one of the most enraging things about,
and I,
you know,
I've talked
to people who were actually victims of rape about this,
right.
And they are fucking furious because it,
it,
it trivializes what happened to them and it also makes it much harder to report
rape.
It makes it much more harder.
It makes it much harder to take people for people to take seriously what
happened to them.
It's an ultimate cry wolf scenario.
Yeah.
I mean,
so you gotta,
you gotta be really disciplined about your definition of it,
of sexual assault and rape.
It's the use of force,
the threat of the use of force or having sex with someone who is incapacitated.
And that is it.
And I think that's good enough.
That is good enough.
And I also think we should enforce like hell that absolutely,
you know,
and in all sorts of ways,
right.
So,
but that's it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I also think that there's an issue with influencing people's ideas of the
past,
influencing their memory.
I mean,
one of the worst pieces of evidence you would know this as good as anybody is
eye witness accounts.
They're terrible when you,
when you,
you ask people like,
I've talked to friends about scenarios that I was involved in where,
and they'll give you a take on it and you go and I'll go,
no,
you didn't do that.
Mike did that,
right?
Don't you remember?
And they'll go,
oh yeah,
fuck yeah,
dude,
we were in Chicago.
We had to go to that.
We have to do that show.
Remember?
Oh yeah.
Fuck right.
You were telling a crazy story about Vegas that didn't even happen in Vegas.
And it wasn't even the guy you were talking about,
but you were so fucking sure.
Right.
And it only happened six months ago.
I mean that is so common on,
and I'm not trivializing traumatic incidences that really get etched into
people's consciousness,
but there is a reality that eye witness accounts are very difficult to cooperate
because people,
their memories suck is human memory.
And um,
and I've,
I've said this on this podcast may times my memory is dog shit,
but it's really good.
Like for a person it's really good.
Like I can pull things out of the past.
Um,
I'm like my MMA documentary,
my MMA,
a memory rather.
It's fantastic.
I can recall fights from,
I've noticed decades ago off the top of my head.
I'm not using any notes.
I can just,
sure.
But if you,
you asked me to break down day by day,
what happened yesterday,
right.
Fuck,
it's a flashes.
It's like I see like snapshots,
a barely remember what I ate.
I barely remember where I went first.
I mean,
I didn't have to concentrate and think about it.
Right?
Well there's us,
his subjectivity,
right?
And interpretation.
So you and I could watch the exact same thing happened right in front of us
right now and have a different interpretation of what happened.
And having someone who's an influential person talk to you about those events
that will shape your perception of them.
So it's really egregious to convince someone that that a terrible thing has
happened to them when they're not sure that it's happened to them.
Right.
Is there,
what does the vested interest in making sure that this person decides a terrible
things happening?
I mean,
this is is you're dealing with people that don't like men.
Are you dealing with people that don't like young boys?
Are you dealing with people that don't like masculine sexuality and they're
trying to suppress it in any form possible so to,
to mute or neuter men in this way to make it so they're terrified to have sex
with someone unless they have like written consent during various stages of the
sexual act.
I would like to record on record that we're about to have sex and you are sober
or you sober.
Is that correct?
Yes.
Okay.
Let's proceed.
Yeah.
I really,
I'm really hesitant about going from motivations and these things when it's
about politics because people do that to me all the time.
Right?
Oh,
you made that argument because you're a racist.
you made that argument because you're a man.
Oh,
you hit made that argument because your mom wasn't good to you.
Whatever.
Check your privilege.
That is,
oh boy.
It's all the time.
Um,
so I,
um,
however it's been shown that men named fattiest have a lot of privilege too,
by the way,
cause sure,
man,
it means great.
Leader did,
uh,
um,
well there is this,
there is this sort of phenomenon that some of us have identified,
which we call the white savior complex.
Um,
which you remember Kony 2012.
Yes.
Good Lord.
That's like the greatest example of that.
How did that fucking vantage quick?
Yeah.
Well,
for good reason,
but that's kind of like the greatest example of that.
Uh,
really a really awesome writer named Taizhou Cole.
I'm not sure how he pronounces his name that way,
but it's tee Jay,
you Cole,
amazing writer.
He's actually a fiction writer,
but he,
he,
he's,
he talked about the Kony 2012 and the white savior complex,
which,
you know,
and this is a lot of my work is on this.
It's,
um,
it's mostly white people,
almost all elite people.
It is almost entirely western European and American people who take it upon
themselves to save,
save their social inferiors right.
And they want to go out and find them first of all,
find their,
find these poor,
sad people in the world,
wherever they may be,
whether it's in the ghetto in Compton or whether it's in Rwanda or wherever,
and go save them and change their lives and uplift them and make them more like
us.
Um,
it's,
it's sort of the,
it is the psychological and cultural core of imperialism and to me it has led to
the deaths of millions of people.
So,
you know,
what had Koni 12 results in it literally resulted in I think 500 us servicemen
being on the ground,
shooting people.
Now you could say it,
that was necessary to save those kids from that guy.
Uh,
and just so,
so just so happens historically,
it almost never ends it that right.
It almost always ends in something else.
A bigger war,
bigger shooting war erupts because of this.
And now we need to conquer the whole country as in Iraq.
Right?
That was a humanitarian mission.
Remember that was to save the Iraqis.
Yeah.
Not Exactly.
So how many Iraqis have died just to save them something like a million.
Right?
It's debatable,
but hell of a lot.
It's at least 200,000 to be as many.
But the thing about it,
it's to killing them,
to save them.
Right.
Which was what was said about Vietnam.
So that was kind of this classic line by a general in Vietnam.
He said,
we have to,
we have to destroy the village in order to save it.
Right.
But anyway,
so that's that idea.
It's also this very arrogant,
paternalistic impulse that's a lot of people have in particular a lot of white
people,
but certainly elite people can.
White people I know hate white people.
I'm glad you're with me on this and I want to talk about ludicrous with you.
By the way,
we got to talking about ludicrous.
Okay.
Yeah.
But um,
your bid on ludicrous.
Yeah.
You're like,
what and what was that?
Okay.
White people.
Um,
no,
it's true.
So,
okay,
so you think that,
so the same sort of motivation that people have to do this 2012 Coney thing
cause the same motivation that they have to cry rape.
Well,
to encourage people to,
so because you need to have a victim,
you need to have someone who's suffering.
You need to have someone who's oppressed,
right.
To save them.
Right.
So you gotta you gotta make sure they exist and so you have to create that
discourse,
that way of thinking about them.
And because this young man had a lot going from Ge,
from a good family and a Valedictorian,
except you have an oppressor,
he's an apprentice to vanquish,
obviously privileged.
Yeah.
Sokoni was the oppressor who had to be vanquished to save the kids there.
Uh,
yeah,
I think it's this,
I think I can't,
I don't want to speak for,
I don't want to speak for what's going on in her mind,
but I do think it does line up with Kony 2012,
uh,
that there's,
you have to create an oppressor.
You have to create an,
a victim in order to save them so that you become the,
the night,
the white night.
Well,
how do they justify the,
the boy being responsible,
but the girl not being responsible.
Yeah.
So that's to me fundamentally antifeminist yeah.
And Conservative as hell.
Right?
Because it is,
it says that a man can make decisions,
can have agency when he's drunk,
but a woman cannot,
she's a victim.
She's going to be a victim.
So women can't control themselves.
They can't determine their own lives when they're drunk,
but men can,
right.
That's,
that's like,
that's like a fucking done.
Don Draper says on mad men about women and say,
Oh,
well,
you know,
they're just,
they're dumb and they can't control themselves when they've had a couple drinks.
Uh,
excuse me.
I don't think so.
I mean,
you know,
I think there's,
there's also said that just like a check by the way,
did,
excuse me.
I don't think so.
Oh good.
I say I just saved my job then.
Well,
if you get fired for what you said,
the world is really fucked.
I mean the academic,
well that's not exactly why I got fired,
but we didn't know you can get into that,
which has to do with the ludicrous.
Seriously.
Yeah.
I mean not,
yeah.
Basically.
Basically the,
your bit about ludicrous is,
is actually is,
is very,
very similar to a big argument I made,
which is the reason I got fired.
And what was the argument?
Okay,
so this is about race
and,
and then your bit,
actually I don't think you do.
I don't think he,
did you connect it to race?
Did you see that?
It's like,
yeah,
you didn't.
Right.
So that's another,
yeah,
it was just about people enjoying themselves and that there's,
there's a lot of music that's just so fucking depressing and it's just like,
like,
uh,
like that hey there Delilah song,
which was not even apparently about a girl that this guy dated,
which has even creep and really,
yeah.
So it's about girl that he knew.
So it was good.
It was probably like moving to New York to get the fuck away from this guy.
Right.
He's writing this song.
He did.
Yeah.
I thought it wasn't,
I mean,
you didn't say this,
but I thought it's not a coincidence that a lot of white rock like that is very
depressing.
Very email.
Yeah.
But it's depressing.
You were saying it's depressing and like salad or even saying,
well,
we are,
what we're attracted to is like the melancholy of it.
Um,
and then depth.
There's depth in being somber.
We think there's done whatever we think we value that we think,
oh,
well he must be a deep person.
You know,
deep thinker with real feelings.
He's a human being.
He's a fully realized human being upon.
Yes.
He understands complex stance,
essence of human humanity.
He's not having fun and smiling cause that people are starving.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
There,
there are more important things to do than have fun.
Yeah.
But that's not so that's exactly what you're getting at.
So like so,
so the fact that you compare it to him and it was at the,
where do they call those dirty white single white tea,
what is it called?
The white tees.
Yeah.
They're white dudes.
Right.
And then,
and with ludicrous.
Right.
And his celebration of rims and barbecues and asses.
Um,
I mean this is,
this is my work.
This is,
this is like the core of my work,
believe it or not.
Perfect.
So,
um,
yeah,
when I saw God's work,
I was watching it with my 12 year old son.
You're special.
And
I was like,
totally.
Do you see that?
He just said what he'd done.
He was like,
yeah,
I think I get it.
I like ludicrous a little bit.
Um,
I said,
okay dad.
No,
it's um,
yeah,
it's so much of American culture from the beginning has been defined in that
way.
So like,
you know,
white people have sort of prided themselves on being,
very serious and upright and disciplined and controlled and,
uh,
and therefore they should be the president,
right?
Or the CIO or you know,
the professor.
Right.
Um,
and they are the good puritans right at the,
invented this shit.
And they adhered to it more than others.
Not Perfectly of course,
but they adhere to it more than others.
And they always took that as a source of pride.
Right?
Yeah.
Man,
we're still repressed.
Yeah.
We don't,
we don't run around naked and fucking in the bushes and,
you know,
we don't,
we work hard.
You know,
we believe that work is a good thing as opposed to those other people.
Right.
People we brought here from Africa who didn't have those ideas,
right.
They're always just naked who's trans.
They dance and they don't think that work in itself is godly.
That's the Protestant work ethic,
by the way.
It's not,
not work as a means to an end,
which makes sense to all of us.
You got to get shit.
You got to work hard.
The Protestant or puritan work ethic is we're,
and this is what they said,
work in itself is good.
No matter what you get for it,
you don't get,
if you don't get paid at all,
if you don't make anything out of it,
it's still,
you should work.
Right.
That's what they've always said,
right?
So you get valourized for just working hard even if you get nothing for it.
So that's been kind of this kind of to me in a lot of historians has been kind
of like the central cultural split in our,
in our,
in our country for 400,
500 years,
um,
between those two.
And you kind of nailed it and that bit,
and I was kind of stunned.
I was like,
oh my God,
he's started,
gets all that you didn't,
you didn't connect it to race.
Um,
but the roots of it,
and this is in my book,
this is what I do with it.
You know,
I,
I tried to find the roots of it.
I'm like,
how did this happen?
That black people created jazz and rock and roll?
Is that just a coincidence?
A lot of standup comedy and comedy.
Right.
So Richard,
yeah.
Not really like Lenny Bruce is the real godfather of comedy.
He's the,
the,
he needs a Jew.
He was the real God,
but he was doing heroin with black jazz singer.
Exactly.
I mean he's,
he's hanging around with exactly a lot of beat poets and they were hanging
around with a lot of jazz singers.
They were smoking marijuana with,
you know,
a lot of black guys.
It was,
yeah,
it was a cultural infusion there.
There was a lot going on and it was one of the reasons why a lot of his
subjects,
one of his more prominent subjects had to do with race.
Right?
Yeah.
A Chitlin circuit preceded him.
Moms Mabley preceded him.
Red Fox,
I think was the same time.
And I think before him as well.
So yeah,
I agree with you.
But prior was the god of fire and he came out of Lenny Bruce.
Yeah.
You think so?
He very,
very strongly influenced by him and discussed it in great,
great length.
Really.
Prior to that he had seen Lenny Bruce several times in the village.
And there was a Lenny,
Bruce was the original.
This is pretty,
pretty much everybody agrees with that when it comes to standup comedy prior was
influenced by him.
Yeah.
Everybody was well,
okay,
that's fine.
I still have an argument for that.
Which Jews,
right?
Yeah.
And she was absolutely Jews and blacks have dominated stand up forever.
Right.
You know,
um,
why?
Right.
So here's,
so here's why blacks have and,
and you know,
so it's,
it's not just comedy and it's particular kind of comedy,
right.
It's like,
it's,
you know,
there's fun loose body,
um,
you know,
saying things you're not supposed to say light company,
talking about fucking in the 1950s and sixties when you definitely weren't
supposed to do it.
Then taking drugs,
you know,
and like making light of that,
that was not okay.
Lenny Lenny was the martyr for that.
Right.
And he went to jail for that shit.
So he didn't really talk about it onstage prior really talked prior.
They plug it in and just blew it up.
Yeah.
Prayers is my major influence.
People when people ask me like an academic conferences like soon as your major
influence.
And I'm like,
well Michel Foucault and Richard Pryor.
And they're like,
what?
It's true though,
it's absolutely true.
When I saw live in concert was 13,
12 or 12 years old.
I first of all fell out of my chair and the theater and I was like,
that changed my life.
Me Too,
because he,
one of the things,
one of the many things he did was I think he was the first person to do this
first black person to do this in public on a stage.
He made fun of white people and suggested that they were actually inferior.
Like that did not happen before.
Like imitating them and putting them down and sort of suggesting,
not suggesting,
basically saying,
yeah man,
like they're layer.
There's Nice sock.
Yeah.
He has this great bit.
It's not in live in concert.
It's in a smaller piece.
Um,
he's like,
it says something like a man,
a white people,
white people,
white people be doing yoga.
Niggas be fucking right.
And it's like,
that sums it up.
Right.
And so,
um,
but so slavery.
Okay.
All right.
Can we do slavery?
Sure.
Okay.
Now I'm going to get fired like four times.
Can only fire you want and you're going to get in trouble too.
How can I be in trouble if you agree with me?
Okay.
I'm gonna agree with you already.
How about that?
Cool.
All right,
so here it is.
So yeah,
if you got to understand like puritanism and American culture from Plymouth rock
all the way through the 19th century first.
Okay.
Which was unbelievably repressive.
And this is,
everyone agrees on this,
right?
It was like comically repressive.
Uh,
this first surgeon general,
the United States,
Benjamin Rush wrote these books about how masturbation caused blindness and
death in epilepsy.
There were just like medical journals were full of this shit about how sex was
terrible and would kill you and cause paralysis and all this stuff.
One of the fastest growing industries in the early 19th century,
right after the United States is founded was for devices to stop people from
masturbating.
So like chain mail mitts for men and these hobbles that kept women's legs
together.
Well,
they had a lock and key and then chastity belt,
everybody knows about that.
All these devices.
It was just this amazingly like comically repressive culture around sex and then
also around work.
So the puritan work ethic that work is good no matter what you get for it.
And you're doing the devil's work if you're not working.
Um,
was in like five year old children's textbooks,
kindergarteners,
we're taught that playing with their toys was the devil's work and they were
taught to be useful in their lives and then to find a profession and a vocation
when they're in kindergarten.
Right.
And it just suffused the whole society.
So like every political leader,
every business leader and certainly all the religious leaders,
everybody and novels that were written,
poetry is just all about work all the time to be godly and never have sex.
Even in marriage,
there was even a lot of talk through the 19th century about even,
even having sex with your wife was dangerous at best.
Like you did it,
you did it because you had to,
to procreate to make more Americans.
But that was it.
Like you gotta be really careful.
You can't let it get out of hand.
Beyond that,
you've got to just,
yeah,
so this is an historians all agree on this.
It was just a phenomenal,
so this is Victorianism,
right?
This is like when puritanism moves into Victorianism,
What was the cause of all that?
What?
That's an awesome question I had no one can answer.
I mean,
what is the,
what is the cause of a culture emerging?
I don't know.
I mean one thing,
one of the more common,
one of the most common explanations is industrial,
right?
So this is,
this is also the time of the first factories.
You know,
and this is the time when people are moving from the farms into cities and
working in sort of industrial capitalist formats,
right?
Where they're sitting at a table and there's a division of labor and you put
together the,
the machinery or the shoe piece by piece and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
So that required or you know,
that requires a lot of discipline,
right?
It requires getting people to stop drinking and stop fornicating and to,
you know,
be committed to work as a good thing.
I'm not sure that's,
I mean that's a decent explanation.
I'm not sure if that really explains it entirely.
Um,
first of all,
cause it Kinda preexists it,
you know,
the puritans were way before all that happened.
Um,
and they were talking about that for centuries before there was industrial
capitalism,
but it was this crazy repressive culture that Americans lived in.
It's,
it's funny for us to look at now the things that they were saying at the time
and doing at the time,
but it was just,
can you,
I just hard to imagine living like that.
Um,
okay.
So that was kind of,
and that was also considered to be what white people do,
you know,
that's,
it was a,
it was totally racialized.
Right?
So it's like white good Americans,
white meaning white people do that.
They don't fuck.
And they work.
They pretty simple and Kurt's over their piano legs.
Yeah.
And also,
I mean,
and that kind of extended to dancing.
So there's,
I have a,
I have a whole section in my book on dancing.
And so like,
it was terrible to dance,
to dance in American culture if you're a white person.
Um,
leisure was bad.
It's all bad.
So that's how,
that's where everyone lived.
And then along come these people from this other place called West Africa where
none of these ideas existed.
Like the Protestant work ethic was like,
what are you talking about?
It just a purely northern European and American invention,
you know,
very few people in world history of us subscribe to that idea.
So the west Africans come over here.
They also believed and moving your body as a good thing.
You know,
it was a beautiful thing to them moving it and sensual ways,
dancing and otherwise they didn't believe that sex outside of marriage was
wicked.
It was going to destroy your life,
especially for women.
They thought that women who had sex outside of marriage were fine,
that it was no problem.
Uh,
they come over here and then as slaves they have zero of course incentive to
internalize,
to adopt this white person's culture.
Right?
Um,
not only that is sort of physically barred from it,
right?
So there,
so citizenship,
they're not given citizenship,
right?
And that's not good because you don't get to vote and you don't get equal
protection under the law.
And all those good things that come with citizenship.
What people miss about it is that in this column here and everywhere,
citizenship is also a cultural thing,
right?
You're considered a good American if you do particular things right.
And in that case it meant putting your body in a walking prison,
right?
That's what a good citizen did.
A good white person.
So slaves were here,
they brought elements of this west African culture that thought that sex was
okay and that work was a means to an end.
And that was it.
Uh,
and they had no incentive to adopt this insane,
repressive culture that the white were all about.
And so they developed their own,
which wasn't west African and it wasn't American.
It was this new thing called Africa,
which we now call African American culture.
And that is what gave us jazz man.
And you know,
because what is jazz?
Jazz is the music of improvisation.
It's the music,
it's been called the music of freedom.
You take this musical structure and then the soloists does what he wants for a
moment and he goes out of the structure and is free.
He's liberated from the structure and then comes back into it.
It's the music of improvisation and freedom.
I don't think it's a coincidence that people who were separated from that
ridiculously repressive culture created that music.
White people never could have created that ever.
But that is absolutely fascinating.
So how much has influenced our culture that has come out of the people that were
brought over here as slaves?
Oh,
it's it,
that's just the beginning.
That's the most obvious one that everyone knows about.
Um,
people make fun of Ebonics,
right?
Remember that when he'd gone x was happening and it's just like 15,
20 years ago,
I was like,
this big joke.
I'm my God,
it's the one they were actually teaching it.
Well,
yeah,
actually a friend of mine is,
uh,
wrote the book on it.
And,
um,
well,
so think about how often in a day that you use what used to be called black
slang.
Right?
We all do all the time.
Even professors,
even like fucking Bob Costas uses it now.
Like Bob Costas.
Yeah.
What did I hear you?
What'd he say?
He said something like,
what did he say?
It wasn't something like dope,
but it was something like,
I forget it was some black slang with her and be like,
God,
see if you,
if Bob Costas is,
is saying this then,
but no,
it's there.
Cool.
We've done no,
no,
no.
It was better than that.
Uh,
but yeah.
Cool.
Is One bad bad is another one?
Yeah.
Oh,
but no,
we've,
there's quantitative studies on this.
So the number of words that come from black vernacular is immense in American
English.
Immense,
I'm sure.
And so much of it is now perfectly respectable.
Right.
Um,
all of that when it,
but when those words were invented,
fuck,
that was like stupid nigger say that,
right?
I mean,
right.
You know,
and now it's like,
ah,
that's,
that's great.
Um,
yeah.
So from the beginning I called them America's original renegades from the
beginning.
Black working class culture has been the main,
not the only,
but the main counterpoint to this puritanism it's been with us ever since.
That's absolutely fascinating.
It's a very interesting scenario to picture what America would have been like
had there been no slaves.
Had the African American culture,
not sort of,
you know,
it would be Sweden.
I mean safe,
pretty safe.
I mean something like that.
Yeah.
Like Switzerland.
Something like that.
So I'm very homogenous.
Very,
very re,
uh,
restrained,
you know,
I mean,
hey,
the streets are clean though,
right?
You know,
but so it's order over spontaneity and it's,
um,
and it,
it sold,
it totally changes what America is.
Oh yeah.
Cause America we like to think of is the hub innovation,
the hub of artistic expression and creativity and entertainment.
90% of the great entertainment that the world has ever created comes from right
here.
Take black people out of American entertainment.
My God,
my God,
what are you left with?
Yeah.
Where the fuck would,
where would,
right.
I mean,
think about led Zeppelin,
it's been shown now that led Zeppelin pretty much plagiarized a giant chunk of
all of their music from old blues songs.
Yep.
Yeah.
The stones or the coolest about that.
Cause they were like from the beginning and they were like,
nope,
we're playing black music.
That's what we're doing.
We're playing the blues.
That's who our influences are.
That's what we're about.
Yeah.
Wild horses.
I mean,
come on it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
yeah,
just watching Keith Richardson on a felon and he was saying that he was talking
about,
oh,
Chuck Berry,
he was like,
yeah,
I am nothing without Chuck Berry.
Yeah.
So,
well,
the Beatles and Chuck Berry had a close relationship to that.
Absolutely.
There's so many of those early guys.
Little Richard,
another beautiful example.
Sure.
So many of those early performers that directly influenced the course of rock
and roll.
Absolutely.
It's a black music.
Wow.
That is a fascinating point.
So if you look at it,
so here's the lineage,
right?
I mean,
you know this,
but just to quick primmer review,
I mean,
it's,
so it's,
it's slave music,
right.
Which has been called various things.
There were spiritual,
but they're all,
it's also dance music that they invented a,
then there's ragtime,
late 19th century,
which everyone agrees gave,
gives birth to jazz and blues.
And then after World War II it's,
it's a rock and roll.
And then rhythm and blue,
a couple what's called rhythm and blues and soul.
In the 1960s she gave birth to disco in the 1970s which gave birth to hip hop,
so and all of that and goes straight back to the slaves on the plantations.
And this culture that I was talking about,
they was outside of this crazy,
repressive white culture.
So it's this fucking white people.
So it's this crazy.
We got to get rid of him,
man.
That's what I'm saying.
Malcolm X had a point.
Everybody's got a no,
I don't want to get rid of white people that I want to get rid of whiteness.
Seriously.
We need spray tans.
So that's what you're saying.
No,
no,
no.
It looks ugly.
It's orange.
Orange is not good.
Yeah.
Colored.
They don't mean orange.
Exactly.
Not on this planet.
This planet not Bluey.
Oh,
but Jews,
man,
Lenny Bruce,
right?
So I have four sections in the book on this and so on.
Immigrant groups.
And I look at,
I look at,
uh,
Irish immigrants,
Italian immigrants in Jewish immigrants.
And one of the things that blows people away,
they don't know this.
Most people don't know this.
When all three of those groups first got here.
So the Irish was early 19th century.
Italians and Jews was late 19th,
early 20th century.
When they came here in large numbers for the first time,
they were not considered white.
So people who looked just like me,
white as hell,
we're calm.
And,
and not only just not white,
they were considered,
the Irish were considered the negroes.
They were considered to be black.
Um,
because yeah,
because they came with this culture that was nowhere near White Anglo Saxon
Protestant culture that we've been talking about.
So the Irish were known as the greatest dancers on earth,
even better than blacks.
They invented tap dancing with blacks in New York City.
Um,
they could give a fuck about working except how much,
you know,
got them in terms of wages,
they believed in drinking a beginning at 8:00 AM and continuing all the way
through the day during work.
Um,
they lived,
when they got here,
they lived with and around blacks because they were poor.
So in the city in New York and Philadelphia,
Boston,
they lived in black neighborhoods and often you see a lot of cohabitation and
you see a lot of what's called miscegenation blacks and whites having sex
together,
procreating Lotta.
Yeah.
So they would call it,
they were called white niggers.
It was very common and a lot of discrimination against them because of that.
And also there's very little evidence of racism among Irish Americans during
that period,
which is weird now because if you think about it,
I mean,
Irish Americans for the last hundred or so years have kind of been unfortunately
the leaders in many ways of,
of white American racism.
But,
but then there's very little evidence of it.
And then what happened was they were like,
wait,
we'd like to get the vote.
I mean they were getting the vote,
but not in mass.
We'd like to get political power.
We'd like to be treated.
We don't have to get good jobs,
be treated like these white Americans.
So there was this very deliberate conscious effort by Irish American immigrant
group leaders and church leaders to do several things.
One of them was to distance themselves from blacks.
So they moved out of the neighborhoods to enter the army and serve in the
Mexican American war and the civil war to prove that they were good white
American civilians and soldiers.
Um,
they entered politics.
They became Democratic Party politicians,
again,
proving that they were committed to the country.
And most of all,
everyone knows this.
They became cops.
So Irish Americans moved into the police forces in huge numbers,
especially in New York and Philadelphia during this period and fire and fire
departments.
And it became a racists.
So there were these big anti black,
there were these big anti-black,
a riots called the New York City draft riots in 1863 which was just this huge
pogrom lynching,
mass lynching of blacks in the streets of New York City.
And that was mostly Irish people doing that.
Um,
and what year was that?
1863 during the civil war.
Yeah.
So it was mass lynchings of black people.
The New York City draft riots.
Yeah.
Wow.
It was ugly.
It was in part resentment against rich people who were paying off others to go
to war for them.
You could do that.
You could sell your draft,
you could sell your selection into the army or you could buy it.
I mean,
I'm so you,
yeah.
You could pay someone to go to war and in your place is what I'm trying to say.
Um,
so it was a resentment against that,
but it actually sort of very quickly turned toward blacks because it was a good
wide belief that the war was for on behalf of blacks.
Right.
To free them.
So the Irish were kind of pissed off at the rich people who were,
you know,
uh,
not going to war when they should have been.
And it was,
but then it very quickly turned to an anti black mass lynching cause they were
blaming these guys for this war that a lot of these Irish guys were volunteering
to go fight in.
Um,
so,
but anyway,
so they,
so if you look at social scientists in the early 19th century,
when the Irish are coming in big numbers,
they're like,
they're negroid,
they're really from Africa or their chimpanzees.
There's a lot of theory among social scientists and so called scientists that
the Irish were actually apes.
Seriously.
Yeah.
Books were written many,
many books.
It was common,
commonly believed by,
by the British and by Americans that the Irish were actually apes or the missing
link between apes and human beings.
That they were actually,
yes,
it was commonly believed that they were actually get this below African
Americans.
That they were actually genetically inferior to everybody.
That the Irish were the bottom of the hill.
Very bad.
They weren't even human beings to many.
What about native Americans?
And I guess they were down there too,
but yeah,
the Irish.
Yeah,
I suppose they were sort of similar to the,
to the natives.
I mean,
there weren't compared to often to them,
but,
um,
chimpanzees,
yeah.
So that's,
that's in my book.
Yeah,
that's what they're called.
They were called the Irish chimpanzees.
Yeah.
Uh,
wow.
And I'm talking about like Harvard professors.
Why?
Oh yeah,
no,
this was,
this was respectable academic discourse.
This was like what in respectable,
you know,
this is all,
this is the first half of the 19th century.
This is insane.
This is when the Irish are coming here in big numbers.
Right?
So they,
the early 18 hundreds and it was partly covered,
professors were referring to I Irish as apes.
Yep.
That's fascinating.
Well,
obviously everyone,
humans and eight,
but,
well,
yeah,
no,
but still,
they still are apes is what they saying.
So then,
so,
but then they go through this route that they go through this really aggressive
process of what's called assimilation.
Right.
They became,
they try to assimilate into the dominant white culture.
Um,
and here's this amazing thing.
So by the end of the 19th century,
just as left,
like less than a hundred years.
They're all the social scientists.
They're doing all these taxonomies of the world's races.
Right.
And they're ranking them and they mail it.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
this is,
this is what my people professors were doing then,
man,
it was hilarious.
And so they would rank all of these races and including in Europe,
they had races in Europe.
They divided Europe into three races.
There were the northern Europeans who were the best ones in the middle Europeans
that were okay.
And then there were the southern Europeans who sucked and who should be,
you know,
ditch diggers.
The Irish were below all of that where the European Jews fit in bottom.
Absolutely.
Oh yeah,
totally bottom.
Yeah,
they were awesome.
Some of the,
like the vast majority of Nobel prize winners.
I know.
Check it out.
Okay.
So Jews,
well,
they may finish the Irish thing.
It's just,
then I'll get to the juice because it's totally linked.
Within less than a hundred years.
The social scientists and all these professors,
et Cetera,
and political leaders,
um,
moved the Irish from chimp to Nordic,
which was the top of the chain.
That was the northern European that was called white man par exsalonce.
So they,
because they were cops and firefighters and politicians and generals and they
hated blacks and they were living outside of,
apart from blacks and they gave up dancing.
I mean,
I'm serious.
He gave up.
If you look at,
if you look at priests,
Irish priests through the 19th century,
that's one of the things that we're very concerned about was that Irish were
dancing too much.
They invented tap dance.
They invent a tap dance,
which is,
or dancing shit.
Well,
yeah,
that's different.
No,
that's Irish Irish.
That's Irish.
I'm talking about Irish American.
Oh No.
They invented tap the tap dance,
which is so much,
which is like the base of so much of vernacular dance.
Now
the Jews.
Um,
there was a prominent social scientist named Arthur Abernathy who wrote a book,
which was very typical of the time in 1906,
I believe.
The title of which was the Jew is a negro.
So the same thing was done with the Jews when they got here and they got here a
little later than the Irish and not in large numbers,
sort of late 19th century.
Um,
same thing.
They were known for their musical ability,
right.
Jews became very famous in jazz,
They have to sort of cofounded jazz in many ways.
A lot of them are gangsters.
That's not okay.
Alright.
Meyer land,
it's very,
very,
yeah,
Mario.
Yeah.
The Jewish mob was as big,
almost as big as the Italian mob when they got here.
Um,
and you know,
they were very considered to be very sensual of the body,
you know,
animalistic and check this out.
This is people,
when I tell my students as I do not believe me,
but it's many historians have written about this.
Jews dominated,
dominated two sports in the first half of the 20th century.
Boxing,
you know this and basketball,
basketball,
they totally dominated basketball,
boxing,
the number of world champions,
many way classes were Jews,
many dozens of them were top and,
and then,
and in basketball they totally dominated basketball until the 1950s that seems
to be the boxing thing though,
in fighting,
it seems to be an economic position thing that when people come over and they're
immigrants and they're the bottom of the economic food chain,
like right now where you're seeing an influx of Russian champions and a lot of
Russian,
right?
A lot of former Soviet Union,
I think it's actually cultural new,
I think,
cause it,
not every immigrant group does that.
Right?
So not Allianz,
Irish.
So when they get,
yeah,
so,
but I think it's,
it's,
it's when,
so hit will,
let me,
so here's the thing.
Here's the funniest thing about Jews and Italians.
By the way,
we're the same category as Jews in many ways.
They dominated a lot of those sports to what was said about Jews and sports in
particular,
boxing and basketball was the,
they were naturally gifted athletes,
Jews.
So the way that,
the way that people talked about Jews and athleticism then is exactly the way
that people talk about blacks and athleticism now.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
To what?
To look at.
Sports writers in the 1920s,
thirties and forties talk about Jewish basketball players and how they're
naturally gifted and they can jump higher and they're faster and they're tricky.
Gear and audits are higher.
All right.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
Blood higher.
But because they were trained on the plantation or something to,
well,
he was genetic as she was about genetic selection selection.
The biggest slaves to mate with the,
is that true?
Does that factual mean?
That's a common stated.
Most of the,
sorry,
most historians reject that.
Really.
There may have been a tiny bit,
but no,
I would think that that's something you would want to do if you have several
generations of slaves.
However,
the big ones to breed with the big ones.
Well,
so this isn't my book too,
but,
uh,
but many historians have said,
well,
if so to,
if you're,
if you're going to be selectively breeding people,
meaning forcing them to have sex with people when they don't want to or
whatever,
right?
Um,
they're not going to work very well for you.
You know,
they're not going to end.
So it's a very tricky thing being a slave master,
right?
Because there's no incentive whatsoever to work.
The only thing,
the only incentive to work as a slave is to avoid the lash to avoid the whip.
So what slaves did typically was they worked just enough to not get whipped,
right?
And not one bit more.
So if you're doing other things to make them want to work even less,
they will.
Right.
And there's not much you can do about it,
right?
Cause you can't whip a slave to death if you whip a slave to death and you have
a zero labor,
right?
So there's masters,
we're always trying to strike this delicate balance between,
uh,
about getting the maximum output from slaves who had zero incentive to work
with,
with wages,
with a wage economy.
Right?
We all have incentive.
We work like Shit,
you know,
just to get the money right.
But there wasn't,
there wasn't that under slavery.
So slave masters actually oddly had this disadvantage in a way.
Um,
but anyway,
so no,
most,
most historians have not found much evidence of genetic manipulation like that.
So that of breeding,
why do,
why are African Americans so much larger physically?
Is it a diet issue?
An African Africans,
I mean the type of pro athletes that you see today,
like football players,
320 pound college seniors.
I'm not,
is that really true though?
Well,
no,
no.
I know that.
But I mean,
if you look at Paris,
if you look at all of all people of African descent in the world now and took an
average height and weight of them,
I don't know how,
how would it compare to people of European descent?
I should probably do a study before we start.
I mean,
if you looked at the Nebraska offensive line,
right?
I mean,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like there's plenty of certainly in America,
right?
So giant white people too.
Giant white people out there.
Yeah,
there's,
but there's like a certain athleticism that's associated with the giant black
people that's not associated with a giant white people who are more lumbering
and they ever running backs.
They're never,
so,
yeah.
So you know Malcolm Gladwell,
the writer,
he's The New Yorker.
Yeah.
So he's argued this and he's a black Canadian and he's actually said in the New
Yorker,
which was amazing.
And he got an a lot of trouble for it.
He's like,
no.
Yeah,
actually we are genetically better at,
at,
at sports.
That's why.
That's why we're faster or it,
oh,
because that's connected to sort of old fashioned scientific racism.
The Jimmy the Greek version.
Right.
But how when you look at all the African American basketball players that are
elite,
all the African American football players that are elite,
all the African American fighters,
boxers that are elite,
how much data do you need to say?
I mean,
well,
but again,
it's all,
yeah,
well yeah,
I mean cause you could be 65 to 80 and ripped and still suck at basketball.
Right.
And so it's hand,
but the guys that are really good at it all seem to be African American and they
can do things like show me a white guy that moves like Michael Jordan and I'll
sit down.
Uh,
there have been some,
there've been some,
no,
show me a white Karl Malone.
Oh,
definitely.
It been chroma loans,
white Chromelin.
Oh sure.
Okay.
There's no one,
there's no any other Lebron,
but there's never been a white Anderson Silva.
That's true.
Yeah.
There's why I just,
there's,
there's certain levels.
I mean,
George St Pierre was an amazing fighter,
but he was amazing.
More for his,
his intelligence,
very athletic for sure,
but not ridiculously fast.
Very physically strong.
But yeah,
he was really good at being unpredictable.
He was really good at the way he would mix up his techniques.
Right.
Well then,
okay,
so then how do you explain that Jews and Italians dominated the,
all those sports?
I don't know.
Not long ago.
Well that's what I'm getting assess could be access to.
They didn't because Jack Johnson was the great heavyweight champion.
I mean Jack Johnson was the motherfucker that everybody was scared.
I know.
But there were more,
there were more at the lower weight classes.
There were more Jewish champions and blacks in the first time.
But there was little or people,
yeah,
well,
but I mean I'm saying,
but they were when you sit her to be and they were awesome.
So supposedly naturally gifted athletes.
Well,
I mean there's still,
there were some great black fighters as well as sandy saddler.
There was quite a few great black mean Griffith.
There was a lot of great black fighters too.
Sure.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know how much of it is access,
how much of it is,
you know,
access to good trainers.
Yeah.
So like the,
at one point,
I think it was in the 1940s,
the something like six or seven out of the top 10 scores and the,
the professional basketball league at the time were Jewish.
Wow.
And now I think the NBA has not one,
not one.
Dollf.
Uh,
Danny Shay's I think was the last Jew that I was aware of who played in the NBA.
He played about like six or seven years ago.
And boxing too,
I mean,
says no,
try to find a Jew.
Yeah,
no,
I think there's like one guy,
I saw one guy like about 10 years ago.
I'm always on the lookout.
I grew up with one,
Dana Rosenblatt.
He was a new England champion.
Ah,
really dangerous.
Dana Rosenblatt.
Yeah.
Tough fighter in the UFC at,
are there any Jews?
I don't think so.
Um,
there's probably a few I've never noticed.
Yeah,
you'd have to.
Uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
It's a good question.
I'd have to go,
uh,
go through the archives.
But as far as champions,
no,
definitely no,
no champions.
Right,
right.
Hmm.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
well,
so Russian.
So you were talking about Russians,
are they Russians are naturally genetically superior.
Well flex.
I mean some of them.
That's why they're so good.
You ever seen provide Nicole?
Yup.
That guy looks like Max Kellerman the best description of villainy.
He said they thought out of Caveman,
put boxing gloves on them.
The provide Niqab is sort of my,
he actually,
I think he serves my argument better cause he's not that talented.
I mean it's just tough.
He's not like he's talented but he's not his,
the relate,
the reason he's so successful is that he's been,
he can get punched in the head 500 times and keep going.
It will powers Chin is,
but its chin is endless.
Chin is very good.
But he also has brutal pal.
But I mean he's,
you don't look at him and say,
wow,
what a naturally gifted boxer.
Right.
Compared to not like,
well Lloyd or whoever is very,
very skillful.
He's,
he's a craftsman.
Yeah.
He's a real professional,
like a real,
but providing a cough is very slick too.
He's deceptively slick.
Sure.
He just fucking hits really hard to,
yeah,
it's a murderous puncher,
but you don't look at him and think,
wow,
he's,
you know,
he's like,
but that murderous punching ability is something you just don't,
you can't earn.
I agree.
There's a thing about punching you either can hit hard or you can't hit hard.
You could take a guy and teach him till the cows come home.
Or You could find some guy who was working construction somewhere and he could
punch a bag and you just go,
Jesus Christ and you know it.
It's like,
it's like throwing a baseball,
right?
It's essentially the same mechanics and,
right.
Same thing with baseball.
You can't really,
it's hard to teach that.
Like,
so you guys just have an arm,
right?
And some guys just don't.
Right now,
look at those guys who have those arms in major league baseball told me what
color they are.
It's all white guys.
Not all.
What the fuck man?
Fuse,
there's a difference between boxing power,
the punching power and throwing balls for some reason,
and I don't know what it is,
but I don't know.
I don't know if they're completely correct.
Uh,
connected.
I don't know.
There's something about getting maximum torque.
I mean,
I just feel like it's,
I feel like it's similar.
I would think so,
but I've,
well it is in some ways there's a guy named [inaudible] who was a very good
pitcher in Japan and he became a knockout fighter as an MMA fighter and he
throws punches a lot,
like see throws punches a lot.
Like the way a guy throws a fastball,
he's always out of balance.
He throws everything behind the shot.
Yeah.
It's similar mechanics I would say and a lot of ways,
but I think,
uh,
well,
you know,
boxing,
I think you can get away with having shorter arms whereas pitchers seems to like
that's a big factor in it.
The mechanical advantage of dawn's frames.
Shorter arms.
Yeah,
but it got maximum.
But no,
but the thing about Tyson that people don't talking about boxing,
whatever,
he got maximum leverage with his body,
right?
People miss that.
They think he was just this huge dude with giant muscles.
But if you look at the way through a hook,
he got maximum leverage.
That's what,
that's where the power came from.
There's lots of guys just as big or bigger who can't punch like that.
Right.
And also his speed was ridiculous.
He could throw a 10 punch combination in two seconds.
Sure.
Like literally you,
there's,
there's videos of him,
him hitting the bags and you just like,
that's like a lightweight,
that's 135 pound guy.
Meanwhile he's two 20 and he also had giant legs and that's where a lot of the
power comes from.
Like if you look at Packy,
owls,
legs,
shoretel has enormous lecture.
But again,
it's the,
it's the mechanics of it.
You could be just that big and punch like a girl,
but you also could be,
you know what I mean?
The mechanics,
it's not the same with everybody.
There's guys that are built like Tyson,
but for whatever reason they just can't generate that kind of power.
Tim Lincecum the giants' pitcher,
he's a great example,
right?
He's like a buck 40 or something is he really can fucking throw 90 whatever it
is.
Miles per hour,
clock 40 I don't know.
He looks like he's very small.
He's very skinny.
Little wire you guy and he,
but they show he like gets this incredible torque and his torso cross his chest.
Well,
proper mechanics are gigantic when it comes to martial arts.
It's a church thing like technique is sure,
virtually everything,
but then there's technique amongst gifted athletes,
but yeah,
I guess so.
Getting that particular leverage and mastering that,
having that mechanics is something that's not really always,
you can't really teach it as what we're getting at.
Right?
Yeah.
I agree with bone structure.
Bone structure is the big one.
Geometry,
body geometry,
George Foreman,
he had canned hams for fifth.
There were the biggest fucking hands ever.
If you saw his hands when he would make a fist,
I have to go walk off.
Fuck.
And that was why George Foreman hit guys on the arms and their arms would go
numb.
Right.
It just had this weird mechanical advantage.
It's true.
Yeah.
The mechanical advantage of bone size and density and shape.
The width of the shoulders as well,
directly translates to punching power.
It's a very strange stuff.
I know.
It mean it's an alchemy.
You can't necessarily,
you can't look at a guy and predict it.
Right.
Not only that,
it's genetically variable.
Like I have a friend,
my friend Ian Mccall,
he's a highly ranked a UFC fighter.
His brother has brutal Powell and he jokes around about it.
He was like,
my brother got the power.
I don't have any,
like his brother has this brutal knockout power.
Apparently his brother doesn't even fight his brother the same size,
like tiny.
I don't know.
Yeah,
But he's just,
that doesn't even matter.
This guy named John Linacre,
who's a fly went tremendous power,
ridiculous knockout puncher.
Right.
And he's 125 pounds.
He hits way harder than anybody else in the division.
It's just one of those weird things.
Why does it,
why can he do that?
I don't know.
I know that's,
yeah.
Anyway,
but he's white.
He's a worker.
He's Brazilian.
Actually.
Linacre is Winokur's.
Brazilla.
Okay,
so he's kind of white.
Yeah,
right.
You know,
the Brazilian,
you can be widened Brazilian.
Oh,
most certainly.
But Brazil is such a melting pot.
Yeah.
Well they have a,
they have a tripartite racial structure.
When Japanese,
a lot of Japanese influence.
There's a lot of black,
a lot of Portuguese.
Of course.
The language being Portuguese.
Sure.
That's a very unique and amazing.
It's weird.
You know,
here you're either white or black and that's all there is.
But there you can be white,
I think.
I don't know what the other one with the name is for the people who are mixed
race,
but they have a name for it in a category,
which is different.
Yeah.
I don't know that there's black,
there's white.
And then there's something else.
There's a lot going on over there.
There is.
I mean,
that's,
that's where all,
I mean,
the real MMA started.
That's the birth of,
I mean that's,
you know,
you want to talk culture.
That's an incredible cultural melting.
So there you go.
How do you explain that?
Right.
So why is,
why is Brazil become sort of the capitol of martial arts?
Well,
um,
it's arguably not the capital,
but it's certainly where it came from as far as like high level mixed martial
arts.
But what's really crazy is it can all be boiled down to one family.
Grace's,
yeah,
it's,
I mean that's the fucking,
that's the seed of martial arts.
That is the one.
But why is it important family?
The why,
but why did it take off like it did in that,
in that particular country,
right.
It's sort of hard until it came to America.
That's what people don't realize present.
Like everybody thought that Jujitsu was gigantic in Brazil.
Like everybody in America thought the Jujitsu is gigantic in Brazil when it came
over here.
Like all the,
all the Brazilians know Brazilian Jujitsu.
Like no,
it was this small clan of bad motherfuckers had figured it out.
And yeah,
they had world championships over there and yes,
the level of Jujitsu is much higher in Brazil than it was anywhere else in the
world.
But it was still a fairly small group in comparison to what it's become today.
And that happened in 1993 when they came to America and started the ultimate
fighting championship,
which was started by Brazilian Jiu Jitsu family and one.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
hoists.
Gracie dominated it and his brother started it all off.
If it wasn't for Horian Gracie,
there would've been no ultimate fighting championship.
If it wasn't for Horry Ann's Father Leo,
there would've been no family of champions that they could show the world this
incredible new style.
Yeah.
It all came from this one family,
which is just amazing.
If that guy wasn't alive,
if there was no Elio,
Gracie,
no Carlos Gracie,
and know my ada,
my ada was the guy who came to Brazil.
The Japanese guy came and taught them judo and Jujitsu.
If it wasn't for those three people,
there's no ultimate fighting championship and mixed martial arts is setback
fucking a thousand years.
I mean,
who knows?
There's more of evolution in martial arts since 1993 then they had been in the
past thousand years.
Oh yeah,
no doubt.
So that's all from three people.
Yeah.
Well,
she's crazy.
No,
it's from millions of people,
but it's three people that started it all off.
My Ada who teaches Carlos and Carlos and Leo.
Sure.
But like the question is,
did
that become so popular?
Right?
That's the end,
which I can't answer.
Culture is hard that you asked him about the cause of cultures,
right?
It's very hard to nail down the cause of a culture.
Why do you know?
Why do we believe what we believe?
Why did that particular thing that's sport become this international phenomenon?
I don't know.
Well,
the,
for martial arts,
for mixed martial arts,
it's pretty simple because everybody wants to know who's the baddest
motherfucker on the planet.
We always thought it was a boxer until we saw box or getting taken down and just
strangled at will and they were so helpless and we saw like James Tony,
who's this great fighter who's like one of the best boxers,
pound for pound,
I mean of our generation changed.
Tony's a outstanding boxing Ranko tour,
takes him down like it's nothing and just dominates him.
Like,
like a joke,
right?
Like you didn't belong in there.
But see,
that's a cultural question to why do we like to know who the best bad acid,
who the biggest bad ass is?
What the,
what's the most effective martial arts,
right.
Cause that's cultural.
That was,
that was the Chris genetic,
just a male thing.
That was the founding question of the UFC,
right?
What is the best,
most effective martial art?
Yeah.
So answering that was what the UFC is mission was,
right,
right.
In a way.
Right.
So,
but that,
that kind of begs the question like,
why do we give a shit?
It's just a male dominator chimpanzee DNA that's still running around inside of
our heads.
Well,
you know,
why do we,
why do we want to know who has the biggest dick?
Why do we want to know?
What's the biggest,
all of his do know?
Well,
some of us do.
Pretending you don't care.
Some of us don't need to ask.
Listen,
that's cute
that,
I mean,
these are questions that are just,
they're just normal natural human questions,
especially when you're dealing with primates suddenly think is good enough.
I'm always skeptical when people make claims about clusters.
Well,
no,
it's not.
No,
it's a natural determinism.
Tracing it back to something in nature and I think it's very tricky to do that.
Well,
this is also,
we live in an incredibly war luck society and we are running on the momentum of
many,
many wars and the,
our dominance over these wars,
I mean our,
our victories,
World War One,
World War II,
not so much Vietnam,
but all this other,
the military industrial complex,
which is sort of infiltrated the entire world with military basis.
I mean that,
that's our DNA.
It's one of the reasons why Canadians are so much different than us.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
You think that Americans have gone to war the way we have for some biological
reason?
No,
no,
that's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying main Tim of those,
those conflicts is a part of our culture.
Oh,
cultural DNA and the momentum.
Yeah.
Not,
not DNA,
like as in genetics,
but cultural DNA.
Yeah.
I'm not sure the momentum of it.
The fact that we're all born in a society that watches,
I mean,
how many fucking war movies have there been?
She's Christ.
I mean every time you turned around,
there's some new about Americans going and kicking ass and war and fighting
battles and kill the Nazis,
and we probably made way more movies about Nazis.
You know about killing Nazis.
I mean,
we're still making it.
That quote was a Clinton inglorious bastards.
Yeah.
I mean there we still look good Nazi killing movie.
Fuck yeah,
man knoweth the Afghans.
I just watched the lone survivor,
Marky mark.
He's going to be Marky mark forever.
Sorry,
I'm that age and I can't get up when you're that my edge.
You can't get over it.
I say it too.
I just thought it was funny that you would call the week.
You have to be it.
You have to be our age,
right?
Yeah.
You're in your forties he's Marky mark.
I'm sorry,
Mister Walberg.
I'm sorry.
Very good actor.
Nothing but killing a lot of Arabs in the movies.
Right?
True.
Yeah.
Interesting.
But the idea being that we have a very war like society.
Absolutely.
I mean the probably arguably the most warlike you look at in terms of like
history.
I would not argue against that.
Yeah.
It kind of has to be if there's a hundred plus military basis all throughout the
country,
if you look at the world,
the world around there,
and if you look at casualties and you know,
um,
created by American military interventions,
right?
Beginning with the American revolution,
civil war was a fucking bloodbath.
Spanish American war,
which we all forget about,
killed tens of thousands of Filipinos,
world war one,
another,
fucking blood death.
What's the,
what's the total number for,
since the 1776.
Awesome question.
And I should have,
I said,
I'm surprised I haven't added it up,
but,
um,
I more or less than 50 million.
Oh,
did Americans have killed?
Yeah.
Well that's the hard thing to determine.
Well,
first of all,
a lot of these people we don't know about,
right?
Cause like Vietnamese,
we don't know exactly how many people died under those bombs.
Right.
Uh,
the,
you know,
the estimates range from one to 2 million Vietnamese died in that war,
but we don't know.
I mean,
a lot of them were vaporized.
Um,
so or just died in the jungle and no one ever found them.
So,
but it's not a bad,
I would guess that the u s the United States of America is probably killed more
people than anyone else.
What about his con?
Oh God,
we crush him.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Cause first of all he wasn't using modern weaponry,
but do you know how many people he killed?
No,
but I,
there's no way he's Monday.
Do you think?
I have no idea.
But it just,
just Hiroshima alone.
There's no way he killed that many people.
They believe that [inaudible] has cons.
Lifetime between the time he was born and the time,
you know,
his direct lineage died between,
depending on who you ask,
20 and 70 million people,
11% of the population of the world.
How are they counting that though?
I have no idea.
Yeah.
Not with weapons.
I mean some of that could have been disease and they just location and
starvation and killed entire populations of cities.
They killed a million people wrecked murder and people,
they had so many bodies stacked up that the is Meehan.
Shaw had sent this a the scout team to go checkout Gin China.
They had gotten there after the Mongols had already invaded and they getting,
they had abandoned
their mission because the roads were so covered in dead bodies and decay that
people were getting sick and dying.
The roads were filled with mud and the mud was actually the d,
The decaying bodies and made the roads unstable.
They saw a pile of bones in the distance that they thought was a snow covered
mountain and as they got closer they realized it was bones.
Yeah.
Dan Carlin's hardcore history does a five part on,
on the wrath of the cons.
Well,
so much so that there was a recent study that showed that they did core samples,
that the carbon footprint of earth changed during his lifetime because he killed
so many people.
I didn't know this.
Okay,
so fine.
So we're second 11% of the people of pop on the,
on the,
on the earth where the runners up then.
Okay.
He can,
he can be the champion.
He went,
he's,
he wins in a big way because they were using fucking arrows.
Yeah,
exactly.
And bodies that they would light on fire and shoot with Caterpillar.
That's impressive with no nuclear bombs and no tanks.
That's impressive.
And know fighter jets be.
Yeah.
But my,
my,
the reason for bringing that up is I wish you had known more about Genghis Khan
cause I would have asked,
well how does someone,
how does a culture become that warlord?
Right.
Cause that was like some complete next level shit.
Yeah.
But even experts in that field wouldn't be able to answer that.
Right,
right.
I mean I don't think,
I don't think they can even try and speculate.
It's too far off for that era.
There's so few records.
It's really difficult to do history.
Right.
I mean we know some stuff,
but it's,
we know so much less than we do about the 20th century.
Right.
Yeah.
1220 you know,
what the fuck did they write down exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
They do have the secret history of the Mongol race.
I mean they,
they wrote their own history,
but you know,
right.
It's hard history being written by the winners.
That's difficult anyway.
Exactly.
When the winners actually killed 11% of the population.
Who else is left?
What are they going to say about it?
I wonder.
Hmm.
Well,
they were saying in Carlin's work,
he was talking about how that's,
there's a great argument about Iraq and Baghdad literally never recovered from
Kangaskhan invading and the 12 hundreds like that was the,
the Muslim people,
the Islamic people were at the head,
the front of the line when it came to science and philosophy.
And it was just a completely different idea of the Islamic culture then we look
at today.
But kingus Khan,
they sack Baghdad and killed everyone,
killed the entire town.
They were the original double tap missile.
Not only they would kill the entire town,
they would go away and then come back several days later and kill anybody who,
who had been hiding.
I mean,
they were just unbelievably ruthless.
So was there an ideology driving this?
It's a good question.
Yeah.
I don't know her know about it.
I just know what I've heard him talking to me.
I'm just a lowly us historian.
We don't,
what's the ideology for what we've done?
Ah,
well that's another question.
Yeah.
I mean,
hey,
it's a good question.
So I mean,
God,
guts,
glory,
Ram.
Yeah.
Well,
so there's that.
The John Mccain School,
right?
Which is like defend American honor.
It's very masculine
and they wronged us.
So we gotta go fucking avenge ourselves.
I mean,
I do think that's like,
that's kind of like the base of the Republican Party,
you know?
I think that that's why they want to go abroad.
They don't,
it's not really even ideological.
It's Sorta this primal masculine urge to defend one's aren't family and honor.
Um,
that's,
that's one reason we've gone and killed people.
Um,
then the other is economic,
right.
Which everyone knows about,
you know,
the war was for oil,
right.
Or natural resources or,
um,
you know,
strategic advantage against our enemies.
Right.
And then the third,
which is what I talk a lot about,
is this humanitarian shit,
right?
Which is like,
we need to go out and save the world and we need to go out and make people be
like us.
Um,
and I think that drives actually a lot more foreign policy than we give it
credit for,
especially now,
especially with the Obama administration.
So if you look at people inside of his administration like Samantha Power and
Susan Rice and even Obama himself,
and even Joe Biden Day,
they really come from that kind of thinking about,
you know,
they're like community organizers or people who did go out into the ghettos to
like uplift these poor people.
Right?
That's right.
That's who they are.
So they've,
and they've said this if you ask them or read them,
but they have to say,
they said,
we need to go and save the Libyan.
So that means we've got a bomb.
Libya,
we need to save the Syrian.
So we've got to bomb Syria.
We got to save and they're big on Africa.
Susan Rice and Samantha power had been calling for in VA basically invading
Africa for a long,
long time to stop another Rwanda from happening to stop another genocide from
happening.
Um,
they,
it's,
it's just very,
it's this incredible thing that Americans and the British really kind of created
and perfected over the last hundred and 20 or so years.
The British were all about this,
right?
A South Africa.
It was all about,
you know,
it was about taking the goods down there,
the diamonds and the minerals and all that shit.
But it was also about uplifting the savages and all of Africa.
So is it having this ulterior motive,
uh,
like justifies the invasion,
like,
you know,
no.
See that's the resources there justifies the invasion.
Right?
Some people think that that they're being dishonest.
I don't,
I think they're true believers.
Not all of them.
Not all of them,
I think.
Do you think Obama is a true believer?
Oh yeah.
I think he,
and if you read his stuff,
a lot of people don't know this,
but like if you read his an article in 2007 when he was just starting to run for
President and Foreign Foreign Affairs Journal,
he says,
American needs to be the world's leader.
And he says with that,
for that to do that,
we need to increase the military dramatically.
We need to have more marines,
more army soldiers,
the whole nine yards.
He called for increasing the military budget.
People don't realize this in 2007 and he said,
because we need to lead the world.
We need to be everywhere in the world.
Hillary's the same way.
Well,
how do you reconcile the differences between what he said when he was running
for office and what he did when he got into the office?
I think he got a lot of pushback.
You know,
I think a lot of people,
both in Congress and sort of in the public generally have been less and less
interested in war for a lot of good reasons.
And one of the interesting things is it's been,
as you said,
it's been left and right.
You know,
it's been people on the left and the right have been less and less interested in
the war.
So the ef for the first time in decades,
we have Sev,
many Republican politicians who are basically antiwar,
you know,
and,
and powerfully and loudly antiwar like raw rand Paul.
Um,
so sort of like out of libertarian and kind of kind of,
although most libertarians hate his guts cause he's,
he's kind of,
he's kind of diverge a little wishy.
He's definitely wishy for them.
Yeah.
Is that because he's like seen what's happened to his dad and I think it's cause
he's running for president in a real way,
whereas his,
for his dad,
it was always just a protest.
Right.
He wasn't really going to win ever.
So he could be pure ideological.
You think he's playing ball a little bit.
Thanks.
So who knows?
But I see it's a chance.
Small one.
I'd say small one.
It's gonna be interesting.
So what's,
what's going to be fascinating,
and I hope this happens,
is that it's rand versus Hillary because on foreign policy and on a lot and on
drugs,
by the way,
uh,
she's going to be the right winger and he's going to be the left winger.
Sh she,
she sucks on the war,
on drugs and on foreign policy.
He wants to bomb the fuck out of everybody.
And she's all about incarcerating people for drugs.
Really.
Yeah.
She's,
but she's certainly never said anything otherwise.
Um,
and every time she's at been at,
and she's her voting record,
if you look at her voting record,
it's all for the war on drugs,
top to bottom.
And her fucking husband was like a liter of it,
ran on the other hand is not perfect and foreign policy,
but he's way less interventionist and she is right.
Much more hesitant to go abroad with the 82nd airborne and he's awesome on
drugs.
You know,
he's about legalizing weed tomorrow and he's probably
even on the powders,
the big fear that everyone has with,
uh,
the idea of a non interventional,
his foreign policies that some big evil government will build up without,
without us being there to smack them down some isis type scenario,
we'll get completely out of control and,
you know,
start killing Americans abroad and launching attacks.
That's the big fear.
Right.
Well.
Okay,
so,
you know,
that's an argument for having a powerful defensive military,
right?
That's not what we've ever had.
We've never had a defensive military.
Well,
you would know from studying martial arts at the best defense is a good offense.
You can also,
I've heard the other,
I've heard the flip of that,
right?
It's the other way around too.
Right?
Good defense is a good audience of it.
Uh,
well,
I mean,
the point is that the u s military historically has never been used defensively.
Really.
It's never,
ever even a World War II.
I mean,
it's hard to even argue that Pearl Harbor was,
you know,
it was first of all,
a lot of people have said that the Japanese were forced to attack Pearl Harbor,
but,
but certainly apart from world war two,
I mean,
the US military has never been used truly in defense of us.
And that's what people need to come to grips with.
Um,
so,
you know,
if you want to talk about changing that pattern,
and creating a military and a that is truly defensive,
um,
and the culture so that we are interested in our military only as a defensive
mechanism means right then,
then we can have,
we have something to talk about,
but that's not the way it's ever been used.
Right.
And what would,
what would be the argument for,
I mean,
is there,
is there an argument for beefing up our presence abroad to prevent peace or
prevent or to,
to ensure peace rather?
I mean,
is there an argument for like the Mccain School of thought,
like beefing up our,
our positions and all these different parts of the world just to make sure that
like an isis type situation and could never rise up?
Yeah,
there's definitely an argument.
Um,
it's called Pax Americana,
the American piece.
Um,
a great,
uh,
example of that argument,
um,
was a document written by think tank in 2099 or 2000.
Uh,
you may have heard of this,
um,
project for a new American century.
Okay.
Was a think tank in Washington DC,
which was full of people who ended up in the Bush administration
neoconservatives and in that document,
um,
re it's called rebuilding America's defenses.
You can Google it.
It's online.
Um,
in that document they call for a massive buildup of the u s military.
They called for a massive deployment of troops and bases and aircraft carriers
all across the world.
Um,
and they said that that is necessary to maintain world order American dominance.
And they said peace.
And one of the scariest things about that document is that in it,
and everyone should look at this and says,
this is in 2000,
it says,
we can't convince Congress or the American people to go for this program to
spend way more money on our defense,
on our military and s and a step,
build these bases all over the world and send aircraft carriers everywhere
unless they said in the document,
unless there is a precipitating event like Pearl Harbor Harbor.
Yeah.
Um,
now that's always not a truther.
I don't think they actually did fly the,
I don't think the Bush administration was responsible for nine 11 but no
question about it.
It's served their purposes.
Well.
You would know that quote,
there's a famous quote about any situation that's not capitalized on any tragic
event that's not capitalized on is truly a tragedy.
There's some military quote about that.
Never let her.
Well,
I know that what's been said recently has never let a good crisis go to waste.
Right.
That's there.
I don't remember what the quote.
Yeah,
but it's something along those lines.
That's essentially what the idea,
and that's what I've had a problem with a lot of people that say that,
oh,
the government planned it.
Look how they capitalized on it,
man.
Just because somebody capitalize on something doesn't mean they planned it.
It just,
it's much more likely they saw an opening to pass through.
Like that's also been the,
the argument about Oklahoma City when Oklahoma City,
there was a,
a radical sweep of legislation that went through that couldn't go through
antiterrorism type legislation post Oklahoma City and like,
well they planned Oklahoma City.
They blew up that building and they blamed it on Timothy Mcveigh in order to
push this and knows fertilizer bomb.
I mean he's always compelling arguments about it that are really confusing.
Fuck.
Cause you get trapped down that rabbit hole of,
you know,
those wacky websites,
they don't need a conspiracy.
Right.
They got what they wanted in nine 11 and in Oklahoma City they got the
justification,
the rationale for a massive ramping up of the u s military and the state
surveillance apparatus and the rest of it.
But what's your take on false flag events that have actually happened?
Like what?
Well,
okay,
let's,
how about a planned when it didn't happen?
Northwoods.
What's Northwoods?
I don't even know what that is.
You don't know what operation Northwoods is?
Maybe.
Wow.
Operation Northwoods was a sign by the joint chiefs of staff in 1962 and it was
a plan to get people enthusiastic about a war with Cuba.
They were going to blow up a drone.
Jetliner blame it on the Cubans and we're going to arm cumin friendlies.
Okay.
And Bomb Guantanamo Bay.
And,
uh,
they were going to kill Americans,
civilians,
and they were going to blame it on Cuba and that,
that was going to get us,
it was vetoed by,
sure.
Yeah.
This was the Kennedy era,
see Kennedy era era CIA,
which was one of the crazier iterations of the CIA.
Yeah.
So they had a lot of that shit going on.
Then a lot of,
there was absolutely conspiracy,
straight up closed doors,
cigar smoke and sub conspiracies in that CIA and another cis too,
that it was kind of the peak of that,
you know,
blowing up Castro's cigars and all that shit.
Right.
Yeah.
They weren't dynamite and yeah,
it was those dudes.
It's that kind of group right.
Then who were part of that,
so,
oh,
sure.
Larry's idea,
isn't it a real exploding cigar,
like a fucking geniuses.
Yeah.
If you want.
It's a really fun,
I mean,
it's funny now,
thank God they weren't six,
they,
I've never tried these things,
but they had all kinds of plans like that,
that were utterly ridiculous to get to basically to get Castro.
Right.
So,
sure.
I mean,
and I'm sure right as we speak in the Pentagon,
someone's coming up,
coming up with some secret plan to do something bad to somebody,
but wasn't that an issue with,
um,
when the Bush administration was leaving,
they were trying to plan something against Iran.
There was some sort of a false flag against,
I ran the Dick Cheney was a accused of being a part of,
certainly NASA came to fruition,
wouldn't put it past them,
but those,
those things can happen very difficult to organize and pull off.
Absolutely.
And on a scale of like nine 11,
the amount of people that would have to be involved with that,
the point is,
again,
they don't need it.
You know,
like they got the,
as you were saying,
they've got their culture behind them,
but it's also the idea about something like Isis,
like why would you call it a false flag when you could just leave a bunch of
weapons lying around and write a bunch of assholes suit up and get crazy and
then shoot them down.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's,
that's hard to wrap your head around,
isn't it?
That's hard to believe that that's a real,
a real strategy.
Yeah,
it's really depressing and scary actually.
I mean,
if you look in 1984 that's what that is.
That book,
that book is about endless war.
That's the theme of that book and it's looking more and more like that.
You
as a student and a professor of history,
as a guy who's really studied it over and over again,
what do you see us solution to this sort of a quagmire?
Do you see a potential
rode out of this?
Yeah.
Out Now.
That's mine.
That's,
yeah,
tomorrow.
Today.
You know,
I mean,
and that's,
and let everybody over there just blow themselves up.
Let them figure it out.
Isis rise to power.
They have a fucking hundred billion dollars in nuclear power and
just you just deal with it.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think every piece of intervention makes it worse for us.
I do.
I think that,
you know,
until we started bombing isis,
they had no reason to attack us.
Now they have a good reason to fly planes into her
buildings.
It also seems to me that as technology improves and as our ability to kill
people easier and quickly and quicker improves,
it gets weirder and weirder when you're willing to engage in war like post
Hiroshima,
it became this,
the fact that nuclear power and nuclear arsenals existed and it can be done,
but it hasn't been done since.
It's like it's so atrocious and it kills so many civilians and it's so
nonsurgical that we decide we're not going to do that anymore.
But it's always there.
But we're pointing them at the Soviet Union.
The Soviet Union's point,
him at us,
everyone during your,
your high school years and my high school years,
we were terrified of being attacked by Russia and they were going to mutually
assured self destruction was the only thing keeping all this from happening.
But as technology gets better,
it's,
it's almost easier for people to cause mass destruction almost easier now than
ever before.
That's true.
Because even scarier when you're,
you're,
you now you have drones and now you have suitcase nukes and now you have all
this new technology disbursement of toxins and absolutely.
So here's
know,
that's a reason not to piss them off.
So that's my out now position.
Right?
That's what that leads into.
It's like,
let's,
if you kick a dog,
is it more likely to bite you?
I think so.
The CIA would say,
listen,
we need to keep these motherfuckers right.
We want to put our hand right on their forehead.
Let him keep swinging.
That way if we ever have to pop a cap and them,
we'll pull the gun out when I left and
yeah.
But all of that shit was created by US policy.
Osama bin Ladin was trained by the CIA.
Right.
I mean,
dean against the Soviets that he got weapons and training and he was their
buddies.
Right.
They instituted the idea of blowing yourself up.
I mean,
this holy war thing,
this jihad as a holy war.
It really,
that wasn't a part of their culture until the,
uh,
the CIA came along and taught them it.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
It's,
uh,
the whole thing,
the whole history of the last 30 or so years in the Middle East.
That's all,
all the bad stuff is created by US policy,
but it's so hard for us to step out and go low.
Just let them figure it out on her.
I understand.
We were like,
nope,
we gotta be there.
I'll be there.
Keeping the peace out now,
man.
What would you do about isis if you were the president?
Let her,
isn't Russell the people of so,
right.
So there are very substantial armies surrounding isis right now that are not the
Americans,
right?
Kurds have an army,
Iraq has an army.
Saudis don't want those dudes around.
And we're a part of this attack on them.
It's not just the United States attack.
Isis is maybe 20 to 30,000,
19 to 20 year old dudes with something like that.
I've never seen an estimate more than 30,
30 k.
Um,
there are a bunch of fucking teenage lunatics,
you know,
basically.
I mean,
that's the core of them.
And then in terms of like the hardcore membership people,
the estimates,
I've seen her more like 10,000.
Um,
what are they going to do against the Kurdish army,
the Iraqi army and the Saudis?
I don't see it.
Um,
so yeah,
good luck dudes.
And also on top of that,
as I was saying earlier,
good luck trying to impose sharia on a whole population that streaming the
Simpsons through its satellite dishes.
Good luck with that.
But
you see these guys getting their heads cut off on television.
That to me like the,
the big production of taking people,
especially taking people that don't deserve it.
That's one of the weird ones.
To me that's like what could be gained at a cutting someone's head.
I've heard people say terror.
Well yeah,
I've also heard people say that this is to try to get Americans to not go there
and then like that is the last thing.
Of course not.
That would work for you.
Got to kill journalist and cut their heads off and I'm going to demand action
there.
Obviously baiting us into it.
But why?
Uh,
well for the reasons we've been talking about.
They know that if Americans intervene and start bombing people,
they're going to kill some civilians and guests who,
who will be a great recruits recruiting material,
the families of those civilians killed.
So you think it's a,
the strategy to create martyrs?
Probably.
We don't know for sure,
but I put that it would be a smart one.
Yeah,
it makes sense to me.
What a weird strategy.
Well No,
to get the short
sided.
Is it possible that they're just,
they're just not thinking that far in advance?
No,
I mean the strategy is to get us to drop bombs on the people of the Middle East.
Right.
Which tends to the blowback theory,
which tends to cause people to dislike the United States and join groups like
Isis.
Right.
So it's a great,
David Patraeus himself said it's a great,
that's actually a great recruiting tool.
So US foreign policy interventions in the Middle East has served as the greatest
recruiting tool for al Qaeda and isis.
Of course.
Right.
You get people to be pissed off.
I want to see what I mean,
what would cause you to join a terrorist group?
I mean,
the only thing that would cause me to do that is if someone dropped a fucking
bomb on my family.
Right,
right.
You know,
I'd be,
I'd be not a nice person.
Right.
And I'd be willing to do all kinds of crazy shit I wasn't willing to do prior to
that.
Right.
What better way than to bait get the United States to start doing that?
Create a whole population of potential recruits.
Wow.
That's a fascinating end game.
They're not,
they're crazy,
but they're not stupid.
That's terrifying.
It's just,
it's,
it's terrifying.
When I remember when I was a boy,
I think I was probably seven somewhere around then when the Vietnam war ended
between seven and 10,
something like that.
I was living in San Francisco,
so it was between seven and 10.
And um,
the war ended.
And I remember thinking to myself as a young boy,
oh,
they're done with war.
Beautiful.
This is good.
I really remember thinking that like,
like people figured out that war is terrible and will never go to war again.
And then when we invaded Iraq after Iraq invaded Kuwait,
I think I was probably 21 and I remember thinking,
I can't fucking believe were at war again.
Like I thought we were done.
I thought people had realized that war is ridiculous and we'd never go to war
again.
And that was just the tip of the iceberg in comparison to this insanity that's
happened post nine 11 the post nine 11 and sanity is just this perpetual war.
The culture of war.
Every bomb we dropped their perpetuates the war.
That's my point.
Because it creates more enemies or we just fucked so many people up.
There's no enemies left.
Right?
Right.
That's one option.
You can kill all of them.
Kill everybody.
Okay.
Kill them all.
Let God sort of matters.
Isn't that like a marine tee shirt or something?
Do that.
Let's do that.
Let's drop many,
many years,
many new nuclear bombs all across the Arabian plane
and see what happens.
Yeah.
So there's two options.
Kill them all or get out.
Yes.
Or do what we're doing and then show her perpetual war.
Yeah.
That's how I see it,
I think.
Yeah.
Do you buy into the conspiracies like the Eisenhower conspiracy when he was
leaving,
leaving office,
when he was saying beware of the military industrial complex,
there's a machine that wants to go to war.
Do you,
do you buy that?
They look at this as this perpetual war as a constant profit source?
Um,
so defense contractors is what he was talking about.
And then he was talking about also research universities who were working with
the defense contractors.
Of course.
Damn,
they love war.
Sure.
Raytheon once all the wars in the world.
Right.
Um,
allegedly,
no,
definitely.
Um,
but,
um,
are they,
the question is,
are they really running the show?
Right?
To what,
or to what extent are the,
what extent?
Now we know that if you look at Hillary Clinton's list of donors,
it's like she,
she's been called the senator from Lockheed Martin because she gets so many
donations from him and she's,
is she the only one?
Of course not.
But you know,
they have other interests.
They have constituents.
They have all sorts of competing interests.
I think the defense contracts contractors have some power just like the Israeli
lobby has some power.
But I actually at the end of the day,
I think that they're autonomous and I think they have their own motives and I
think a lot of them are,
especially with people like Hillary and Obama and others.
And the neo Kahns under Bush,
um,
had an ideological motivation.
Yeah.
Which was Pax Americana,
which was a world order controlled by us are controlled by them,
I should say.
When you see the difference between the way Obama was like the,
the hope website,
hope and change,
whatever the fuck it was.
When they went into,
they had this whole section on whistle blowers about,
you know,
helping whistle blowers alert,
the American people to crime and to things that are going on that are
unconstitutional.
And then it's all been removed from the website and now you see how horrible
he's been on not just whistle blowers but on the press and on people forcing
people to divulge their sources.
And the worst.
Yeah.
The of you,
it's called him,
called him the worst president on the fuck.
Does that happen?
Is that just a guide that's just under pressure once he gets into office?
Or is that how he was all alone?
I think it's who he was all along.
So he was just bullshit.
You got everyone.
So in 2007,
2008,
when he's running for president,
I was,
I felt like I was on an island in a sea of crazy people because I was reading
what he was writing.
I was listening to his speeches.
I read the Democratic Party's platform for 2008 and in it,
it was all about the military industrial complex.
It was all about expanding American power and control abroad.
It was about increasing the military budget,
increasing the number of marines and army soldiers.
It was about not repealing the Patriot Act.
It was about a very powerful state,
nation state.
They're controlled,
not just people abroad,
but people here.
Dude is always been about that.
Always.
He's always been,
he's always been a nationalist first.
Um,
an American nationalist first and everything else is second.
And so,
yeah,
I was sort of listening to these people talk about him being a peace candidate
and someone who would eliminate the Patriot Act and someone who had,
you know,
never spy on Americans.
And I'm like,
no,
look at who he was when he was running.
He was saying this publicly.
It wasn't keeping it secret.
It just,
people wanted to see something else in him for various reasons
because he's articulate as opposed to Bush because he's well educated because
he's black.
You said black with me.
You were holding on to black.
I was
biting,
biting my time there.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
you know,
one of the most disturbing moments of the debates to me was when him and Mccain
and we're going at it and uh,
Mccain corrected him about Afghanistan and Mccain,
you know,
we were just talking about like just going into Afghanistan and sending in
troops and he's like,
hold on.
Do you know what the fuck you're talking about?
Essentially Mccain was like,
have you been Afghanistan?
Do you know what it's like there like that that place is run the same way it was
run when Alexander the Great was around.
Right.
It's really not that much different.
It's incredibly difficult terrain.
Really hard to get anywhere.
People can hide anywhere.
Essentially.
You have one city in the entire country,
you've got Kabul,
and then you got warlords,
warlords that control small groups of people and they're scattered throughout
the country.
Right.
Good luck.
Yeah,
so when John Mccain is taking the piece position in a debate with you,
yeah.
I didn't tell you something about who you are.
Yeah.
But for me it was like,
now he's a warmonger.
He always has been.
Obama.
Yeah.
Always has been.
It's incredible hope and change,
man.
What are you talking about?
What happened to hope and change restoring America's leadership 2007 foreign
affairs article.
Everyone should read it.
Everyone should take it.
I'll take you five minutes.
Yeah.
What do you think about like the wikileaks stuff and the Edward Snowden stuff
and all this?
This new,
the digital age that we live in is very fascinating to me in that there's just a
certain amount of impossibilities in controlling data when you get to like a
large organization like the United States military,
no matter how,
how well they put up their firewalls,
no matter how good they guard their data,
you're still dealing with human beings and young human beings by the way.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Technology can cut either way,
right?
So it's like,
it's on the one hand,
it's very difficult for those large institutions to control their information
now.
Right.
We can get in there like Snowden did and like wikileaks has,
we can get in there and disperse it and everybody fucking knows what they're up
to.
So that's kind of good I think for democracy and for freedom and for us and for
our privacy and power,
etc. Against them.
Um,
but on the other hand,
they can use it against us and our all the time.
Right?
They have all these cameras everywhere and all these city,
you know,
New York City in London,
I think,
Len,
isn't there a camera on every corner in London?
How about Camden New Jersey where they don't even have coffee.
Exactly.
It just placed the comps with cameras.
Right,
exactly.
So,
yeah.
And you know,
um,
so they're looking at us and the FBI apparently has this thing where they're
looking at us through our webcams,
um,
on our computers.
Got Tape on mine,
but right.
Yeah.
Good,
good move.
I shouldn't watch a middle aged man beat off.
You're on your own.
Get it from me.
They might even want that information.
Let's go ahead.
Beat off the normal stuff.
When I asked me,
I'll show you,
I'll send you the links.
But,
but I'm not a,
you know,
I'm not hiding anything.
If I was like,
say if I was a person in a position of influence and I was,
you know,
concerned about my future and my position in the company and they found out that
I was only watching tranny porn.
Exactly.
Sorry,
I said tranny.
You know,
unless they train anymore.
Yeah.
Right.
Transgender porn.
Dan Savage of all people got into trouble for using the word tranny and that
hilarity believe that shit.
Well.
How about the guy who runs bravo?
What is his name?
Um,
Cohen.
Andy Cohen.
He got in trouble for saying twink.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Calling someone a perfect twink like you can't say 20 there's people out there
that are just fucking professional victims,
you know?
And that's what full circle brings us back to what we were talking about when it
came to colleges.
And that's one reason why I want to play dear woman for you.
Do you have it?
You just pull it up.
You have to see this cause it's this,
this is the white knight and capsulated.
This is the White Knight ideology and capsulated in the most ridiculous form
blood pressures about to go up.
No,
it's,
you're going to love it.
Okay.
It's beautiful.
We stand before
you today as men committed to becoming more conscious in every way we feel.
Deep love,
great respect,
and a growing sense of worship for the gifts of the feminine.
We also feel deep sorrow about the destructive actions of the unconscious
masculine in the past and present.
We want to apologize and make amends for those actions today.
So that we can move forward together into a new era of cocreation is this
beautiful will come more conscious,
conscious play of masculine and feminine energy in me.
Isn't it beautiful?
I know that we all have access to the full spectrum of these energies
and awareness of the dementia beyond all humanities,
freeing Skype like the sky.
I commit to owning your,
discarding a masculinity that honors and celebrates us as equals.
I know truly honor you as a multidimensional woman,
I must stand fully present with myself and own the gifts I have to share with
you.
We can create great miracles together.
Oh my God,
my nurturing each other in a conscious way,
striking each other with reverence and respect and by worshiping at affinity
expressed in the masculine and feminine energies.
What has made our relationship to the feminine has often been unconscious.
I feel sorrow that women and feminine energy for so long been subjugated and
oppressed throughout history.
Men had raped and abused goes on for eight minutes.
Yeah,
we can stop at any moment that,
oh look did playing a theatrical version of,
of pain,
of suffering on the steak.
Bard year from religious and political.
Okay,
stop right here.
You know what it reminds me of a little bit,
you know,
purity balls,
or like girls,
the daughters bracelets.
They had a period,
just the dad just like embracing his daughter and then pledging purity.
It's something,
there's like a vibe vibe there that reminds me of that.
And then will Farrell did a funny or die a parody of it that this guy fucking,
that guy reacted to it in a very negative way.
It was kind of funny.
Oh was he aggressive and violent and he was upset,
upset.
He was angry.
That's a masculine trees.
He was saying,
who are these Weirdos?
I didn't even,
I've never heard of this goes,
they're just losers.
Okay.
The guys that chicks don't want to fuck.
So they come up with new strategies.
This is what I've always said,
and this isn't very unfortunate,
but it is reality when it comes to men.
Men Are Slimy Fox who are making sperm 24 hours a day and we want to have sex.
And here's the deal.
If we're heterosexual and ladies,
if you see a guy and you don't want to fuck them,
don't trust him because if you don't want to fuck them,
chances are a bunch of other girls don't want to fuck them either.
And so he has developed tricks in order to stay in the game.
And one of the best tricks,
it's a separate himself from the pack by saying,
dear woman,
I recognize that duality fucking dork.
I know what you're doing.
I want to take that guy hunting.
I want to put him on a fucking gift.
We give them a rifle and make them hike up to the top of the hill and find your
own food.
He's lacking in all masculine,
positive traits.
These fucking cowering.
I'd rather see a woman,
I want to take them to a single's bar is the only way to see how he does.
Any woman who's not out of her fucking mind,
but that's the question I a heartbeat.
How successful is that?
Completely unsuccessful.
Doesn't work at all.
How many views did it get?
Oh,
probably a million.
But everyone is mocking it just for fun yet,
right?
Yeah.
Everyone feels like,
what the fuck?
I probably seen it 100,000 myself.
Fucking preposterous.
He's a goofball.
But the business,
there's a lot of those goofballs out there that are separating themselves from
the herd.
They see a group of people that are reacting to the Douche bags of the world and
there are asshole men,
frat boys and fuck heads and Bros are ruining everything for everybody else and
aggressive shit heads.
And then they see this and they say,
I am going to separate myself from that and I'm going to be the guy only it's
fucking vegetable matter.
And I,
you know,
I,
I don't even use mass produced deodorant and I brought some ever watch porn.
Never.
There's a great video on that as well that I watched this guy gave a ted talk
about what's wrong with porn?
I think I know who the Spanish accent.
Oh No,
there's a guy who teaches at Texas tech.
Ut Austin does this.
Yeah.
He's kind of the Robert Jensen.
He's the leader of this movement against men's movement against pornography.
Right.
Well what about men doing pornography with men?
There's a problem with the anti pornographic movement is what you were talking
about earlier is that the idea is that sex is bad.
Sex is not bad and no one is trying to stop gay porn.
Oh,
here's the thing.
Unless you're,
unless you're some sort of a fucking church goer and you think that
homosexuality is evil,
there's no movement to stop gay guys for making gay porn.
You know,
men are out there going,
we need to stop these gay men from abusing each other in gay porn.
No,
they like fucking each other.
They do it for fun.
They enjoy the shit out of it and guys like Dan savage,
he'll openly talk about how he,
I mean he was on the podcast just going off about how he watched his gay porn,
sir.
No,
no one has a problem with it.
Zero people have a problem with it.
Pornography is the most democratic institution in our society.
How's that work?
There is no desire that is not catered to in pornography.
There is no body image that is not sold as an object of desire in pornography.
Little Dicks.
There's no little Dick Porn.
All right,
there's one.
Okay,
fine.
No,
but if you think about people that I've heard pornographers say it is,
you know what,
what is your,
what is the thing you hate about your body the most?
Right?
You will find people paying for that in pornography.
It's approach to look at that.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing about having the,
the reach that you have with the Internet.
It's like you'll find a group of people out there and that's one of the weird
things about any like,
really,
really crazy ideology is that you'll find a bunch of people that agree with you
on your adoption of Sharia law and then they'll gravitate to you like a magnet.
You know,
Sam Harris turned me onto this video with a terrifying video of these guys and I
believe they were in Norway or one of those countries.
It's like really open to,
uh,
various religions coming there.
And there's these guys that are doing this Muslim,
uh,
they're doing the speech and they're talking about the idea of radical Muslim.
They're laughing at people calling things radical Muslims.
And He,
in the video,
he starts saying,
how many of you agree with what it says in the Koran about about the way
homosexual should be treated.
Everybody raises their hand that homosexuals should be stoned and that whatever
it says by whatever God's law is,
would be the very best way to handle a situation.
And they all raised their hand and he's like,
this is he,
are you radical and not radical?
You are just Muslims.
And he's like laughing at it thinking that.
I mean the way Harris described it to me,
he's like,
this guy is saying something that he says he has so much confidence in it.
He's like saying it almost like you would say the best way to stop tooth decays
brushing your teeth like something everybody knows.
And he's saying it like that.
Confident.
But he's talking about stoning homosexuals.
He's taught,
you know,
I mean,
it's incredible.
He's talking about women being able to vote.
He's talking about women,
you know,
having second class citizenship status.
This is just how it is in the,
in the Koran.
And they're all agreeing with them.
And it's,
it's,
it's an unbelievable video to watch because you watch it,
you realize like,
wow,
there are people like that out there and they're all,
you know,
they're all praising Allah and in this video and the,
they're all joining together in this and it's this large group of thousands of
people.
And there they found themselves.
Sure.
They found people like them.
They put this video and they took this video and put it online.
And I think the,
the net,
the title of video is,
it's not radical Islam.
Right?
Sure.
They exist.
The question is what to do about them.
Right.
So Sam Harris wants to kill them,
you know,
I mean,
he's,
he's an interventionist.
He wants to think,
he wants to kill them.
Well,
he certainly has said things that sounded like that.
I mean,
he's,
he's a big interventionist.
Um,
he,
you know,
he's,
there's a moment in his book where he,
it looks like he's advocating nuclear assault on people in the Middle East and
he has sort of backed away from that.
Um,
I don't know exactly what was the tens,
but do you remember the conduct?
Well,
he says that,
you know,
if,
if you have,
you know,
x million people who are committed to this fanatical genocidal jihad,
um,
then the nuclear option might make sense.
I mean,
you have to read the book for yourself and he has,
he has back,
he has sort of backed down from that.
Which book was this?
Um,
I can't remember,
but I can't remember.
It's a very sort of infamous quote from him and you know,
he'd have to speak for himself about what that actually means,
but not then there's no question that he's an interventionist and military
intervention.
He wants military intervention against them.
That's,
that's clear.
Um,
the question is what co,
what,
what would that produce?
And my argument is it would produce more of them.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
well,
I,
I've always been fascinated by the laughs adoption of the term Islamophobia and
that Islamophobia is one thing that is very,
um,
it's very chic.
It's in style to call someone out on Islamophobia while mocking Christianity at
the same time.
It's,
it's,
it's an interesting thing,
like you're allowed to mock Scientology,
you're allowed to mock Mormonism.
It's a very valid point of debate.
The fact that Mitt Romney was a Mormon,
he's essentially a cult member.
His family came from Mexico.
They fleed to Mexico so that they can have more wives.
I mean this is undeniable,
right?
And it's,
it's,
it's all fair game and on the table.
But is Llama phobia is,
is interesting.
Well,
it's just that,
I mean,
I'm not a fan of that,
but it is that Islamophobia has particular political applications right now,
whereas the Mormons are safe in Utah.
No one's talking about it in here to Utah and killing the Mormons.
Right?
Um,
yeah.
I mean I look,
if I,
if,
if they ever came over here and tried to convert Los Angeles and to Sharia
Sharia regime,
gimme a fucking AK 47 you know,
and I'll shoot him in the head myself.
My point is going out there and stopping them from doing it to other people is
simply going to create more of them and more importantly,
it's going to actually cause them to wish harm on me to do harm to me.
Right.
I was in,
I was in New York and nine 11,
you know,
I don't want that to happen.
No,
no doubt about it.
I just,
I'm looking at it in terms of why is it acceptable to stand up for one religion
and that religion
then used in such bad ways recently.
That's all it's been used to justify these terrible wars.
Right?
It was used to justify the war in Iraq and Afghanistan and Syria and the rest of
it now.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
A tip,
a critical,
it's a double standard.
Um,
um,
yeah.
I have nothing good to say about Islam.
Nothing.
And I certainly have nothing good to say about that variant of Islam that is
practiced by the people in Isis or al Qaeda or the Taliban.
Um,
yeah,
but so what,
right.
It's like there's all the people all over the world who have ideas that are a
boring.
To me,
that's such a,
it's such a fascinating debate.
It's such an interesting take.
Like which way do you go?
Do you go in,
hey,
let him be crazy over there or do you say,
listen,
that crazy over there is going to eventually come over here.
We've got to figure out a way to plan ahead or we're going to run into a bad
situation that's going to be out of control.
It's about aggression.
So it's about who uses aggression,
right?
So if they aggress against me,
hell yeah.
It's on.
And so you feel like these happened aggressed against the few people that have
been killed over there.
Few reporters that have been snatched up and had their heads cut off on video.
Like this is such a small amount.
Yeah.
I mean,
hmm.
wow.
Not Good.
No,
of course not.
The Isis argument is that they are an extension of the u s military,
um,
that that's there and they're an extension of us imperialism,
is what they say.
That those reporters,
I'm not in any way justifying what happened to them.
I think some of them have in British too,
right?
Yeah.
Well the Brits are an intervening too.
Um,
so you know,
I don't know,
but I mean,
the point is they are,
as I said,
they're trying to bait us in which they succeeded,
succeeded in doing.
Look what we're doing today.
We're bombing them right now as we speak.
And what,
so what will we get from that?
Are we gonna?
Are we gonna kill all 30 or 50,000 of the Isis fighters?
Are we going to do that?
The only way to do that is descend in the entire fucking 82nd airborne and more
and chase them down on the ground and kill every last one of them,
which I don't even think is possible.
So,
you know,
and what you're doing is you're creating more anti-American hatred in that
region from which they can recruit
endless war.
1984.
Fuck.
What's,
what's the way that this can be fixed?
Get Out,
man.
That's it.
That's the only way.
The Rand Paul Way.
Whereas Hillary Clinton,
hell no.
She wants to chase him to the ends of the earth.
Sure.
But she's the one who's been in the office.
What did,
he's been there.
What did Joe Biden to say?
He just said,
we're going to chase isis to the gates of hell.
Whoa.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that's exactly where you're going to take us.
You're right.
That's what exactly did he really say that?
Yeah,
he did two weeks ago.
I remember when Joe Biden,
we used to do Joe Biden night at a comedy club cause Joe Biden got caught being
a plagiarist.
Oh yeah.
Do you remember that?
Oh,
you don't know that?
Interesting Joe Biden,
when he was running for president,
I believe.
Okay.
I started standup comedy in 1988.
So it had to be close on people's minds.
So it was somewhere around then.
Joe Biden got in trouble.
He was running for president and uh,
he gave a speech that was a direct rip off of one of Kennedy's speech.
And uh,
they said,
oh,
you know,
he got speech writers.
He didn't even know.
But I mean,
they didn't even fucking bother changing the words.
They just plagiarize the shit out of Kennedy.
And so we used to do Joe Biden night,
it's stitches,
comedy club and a,
what we do is like a,
I would go up and do one of my friends acts and he would go up and do me and we
would do each others act as a joke and they call the Joe Biden night.
Oh my God.
So I was,
you know,
and he never ran for president again after that because of that.
Because of that.
Cause you fucked with them so badly because of that,
because everyone knew that there was like,
because I remember it.
I guarantee you other folks that are in the know,
especially politically in the park,
they know like that's a big skeleton in his closet.
Like,
look dude,
you could be vice president.
No one's going to dig too deep.
But if you ever get to be president though,
why did you plagiarize fucking Kennedy?
Man,
I kind of
Biden in the way in the sense that he's,
he's not very filtered,
right?
He doesn't edit much.
His thoughts.
So like what he said about Obama
during the race,
you know,
he was like,
well people like him cause he's clean and articulate,
you know,
people,
white people like black guys who were clean and articulate and well spoken and a
thin.
Yeah.
And then Shims.
Yeah,
they looked,
seems healthy.
Exactly.
Jogs a lot and stuff.
He's not little Wayne.
Yeah,
he's safe.
He's okay.
Uh,
I think,
yeah,
I thought he was right.
You know that that was correct and he got into all this shit about it.
Well,
there's no doubt we like white people that are clean and articulate as well.
I mean if you,
you've got to Rob Ford guy running for president and he's,
he's done pretty well in his political career.
You know,
I mean,
Canada,
Canada is a different animal man.
I guess.
So.
Totally different animal.
I'm team for it,
man.
I like,
well,
no,
I'm just kidding.
I mean it's just the fact,
you know,
I'm all about individual freedom,
and like if you're,
if you're smoking crack,
I don't care.
As long as you run the city correctly,
you know?
Yeah.
Why is it okay that he drinks whiskey,
but it's not okay if he smoked.
Exactly.
There you go.
Yeah,
I mean that,
that's the tremendous North American double standard,
right?
Yeah.
The double standard of you know about all too well,
yeah.
Come on.
I mean alcohol compared to weed,
the destructiveness of alcohol.
Well not only that,
the self awareness aspects of it,
the blinding you to your actions aspect of alcohol,
which is the whole thing.
Look,
everyone's talking about being intoxicated in intoxication,
leading to rape.
No one's talking about stone rape.
Okay.
And it's not a coincidence.
Exactly.
It's,
it's,
even though marijuana is illegal,
marijuana is something that I believe probably causes less rape than any other
intoxicant you could ever take.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It makes you paranoid and self aware and sensitive and you're also more aware of
other people's feelings and it's probably the least likely to rape drugs ever.
Of course.
It makes you less aggressive.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
And there's just one of them.
I mean all of this psychedelics and marijuana is not thought of as a
psychedelic,
but I think it's very much like it is.
Yeah,
they're all illegal.
Well that's sort of changing too,
you know.
What do you,
how do you feel about that?
I mean it's an interesting thing seeing the economic aspects of legalization
state,
not federal because the states have adopted these new policies in California or
in Colorado rather and Washington state and now other states are looking at it
and wondering whether or not they should dive in because of the amount of profit
that they're making tax wise.
Yeah.
I,
I money,
I'm for total decriminalization legalization tomorrow with all drugs period.
Okay.
So,
um,
but I actually voted against,
was it 17,
uh,
in California prop 17.
Um,
because if he read it,
it was,
and a lot of people were sending this,
it was written by this guy in Oakland who was going to be the new corporate
chieftain of the weed industry.
And it was written in a way that was going to make it very difficult for the mom
and pops in humble to exist to,
to commercial
to compete.
Yeah.
Cause there's gonna be full of regulations,
right.
It's going to regulate the shit out of it.
So it was some sneaky shit and most likely,
you know it,
this wasn't stated,
but what else is going to happen?
They're going to go to your little farm in Arcata,
California.
And then I'd be like,
what does that hippie doing there?
You've got all these guys who were like long haired and they're,
they're high and they're,
you know,
there's not good workers.
It's,
you know,
they're going to rig it and say,
I'm sorry,
this is not,
this is not up to snuff.
We're gonna have to shut you down.
The guy who's going to run the Walmart of weed in the Oak,
that giant Oakland warehouse he was going to establish in the East Bay up there.
Oh,
he's going to be fine because he's going to be super regulated.
He's going to be very clean.
All those employers are going to be vetted.
They're not going to be potheads be politically connected to all the right and
of course politically connected.
So a lot of the,
a lot of the Humboldt growers were opposed to that proposition for that reason
cause they saw it forcing them out and giving,
handing the reins over to the big and,
uh,
these big corporate entities and pharmaceuticals so that the prediction was,
and I thought it was right that the big pharmaceutical companies were going to
move in and take over and make it into a big corporate industry.
And that's,
I think that's starting to happen in Colorado.
I've seen,
I've seen some evidence of that.
In what way?
Um,
it just,
that there's sort of a monopolization going on.
Did the state Reagan state regulation often leads to the creation of monopolies,
right?
Because it makes it difficult to enter an industry,
If the,
if it's something,
if an industry is heavily regulated,
you have to meet all these criteria to enter it as a legitimate licensed
business,
it becomes more difficult.
Right?
So the existing entity,
the large corporation that's already there,
it gets protected by these regulations is called regulatory capture is the
concept.
Um,
and so I think that's what's gonna happen.
so I,
I want no regulation.
None.
Just legal.
Yeah.
Just let us,
let us grow it and smoke it.
When you say decriminalization,
do you think that it should be legal to sell things like cocaine and heroin and
then heroin especially is a tricky one,
right?
Because people associate that with damaged lives and destruction.
And so the,
the,
the quick one word answer to that is Portugal,
right?
So Portugal decriminalized all that shit.
I mean,
there's some regulations there,
but they decriminalized all those drugs more than 10 years ago.
Well,
that is the difference between decriminalization and legalization legalization.
Like if you're selling pottery,
nobody's gonna give you a hard time.
Like anyone can sell pottery,
but if you get caught with pottery,
nobody gives a shit.
But if you get caught with drugs in decriminalized state,
well then you don't get in trouble.
Right.
But if you're selling it,
yeah.
It's a different animal.
Yeah.
I want,
I want the state to have nothing to do with it at all.
So if you,
but anyway,
so in Portugal,
great study was done by Greg Glenn Greenwald and the Cato Institute about three
or four years ago,
looking at the 10 years of decriminalization,
decriminalization in Portugal.
And what they found was dreek decreasing the number of HIV cases,
not surprising,
a decrease in the number of the Dq decreasing the addiction rate,
which is amazing.
And a decrease in usage.
People actually
use it less than amazing.
Yeah.
So there you go.
People want to do things that are forbidden.
It's a natural impulse of human beings.
He tried to resist and we tried to do it.
Creation of a taboo creates a desire.
That's a such a bizarre thing that we have this attachment controlling people's
access to consciousness enhancing or are or altering substances.
Yeah.
We're completely committed to this idea and we will,
we'll pitch it as if it's the only logical explanation or the only logical
course of business.
Like,
you know,
you're going,
what are you going to have the streets filled with a bunch of reefer heads?
Right?
Well,
you look at what's going on in Colorado,
they have like the lowest rate of drunk driving accidents ever,
right?
They have a lower rate of murder than they've ever had before.
They have lower late,
have lower rates of violent crimes and then they had in a decade,
right?
Like all these things are happening like right in front of everybody's face,
undeniable aspects of the legalization of cannabis.
A drug which makes people more peaceful.
That's right.
I mean it just does.
It's right.
I mean it doesn't make everybody more peaceful,
but it's pretty fucking good at it.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
And so if we decriminalized heroin tomorrow,
are you going to start shooting?
So that's,
but I'm an adult.
The the,
the,
the question is,
is keeping it from young people just making it more difficult to get,
is that going to keep one kid from becoming a junkie?
If it is,
is it worth it?
I,
I don't,
I see that argument,
but I don't think that it jives with human nature.
And that's why I would say that legalization of all drugs,
it probably be better.
And also you're creating,
when you create laws,
when people violate those laws,
they become criminals and you put him in jail and that's where things get really
fucked up because then you have what we have in this country,
which we have privatized prisons and then there's not just one.
It's not what we're not talking about one,
we're talking about many privatized prisons.
So you have a prison industrial complex.
So along with these laws that has a vested interest in keeping these laws
active.
So then you have unions,
like you have the prison guards union,
which lobbies to keep these drugs legal or illegal rather along with
pharmaceutical drug companies,
which form a partnership for a drug free America.
And my joke was that's like hookers making commercials against strippers,
like a partnership for a drug free America.
Going out against weed is,
it's literally like hookers saying strippers are bad,
you know,
like when they're immoral,
like we're better.
Like it's,
yeah.
Why do kids smoked cigarettes?
A lot of it is because there's a taboo on it,
right?
Because it's being,
it's being rebellious,
right?
It's also like,
cool,
man.
It's cool because it's bad.
Well,
it's also,
there's a certain romanticism involved to just ruining your life,
you know?
You know what I mean?
Fucking self destruction ranking,
and it's sexy.
It's the rock star,
self destructive sexiness.
He's fucking gets up at t can't keep a job.
Right?
Blasko you're fired,
Wilson.
Fuck you guys are rebel.
Get his jacket.
He's going to fucking fucked up leather jackets.
He gets on his motorcycle in the rain.
You know,
it's like there's drives off a cliff and every,
and he's in and he's just like international superstar.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean in those,
those movies,
those little shitty Arnold Swardson here,
cop movies,
like there's always a scene where he's like,
he's,
his breakfast is like,
he pours up fucking couple slices of pizza into a blender and you know what I
mean?
It's like there's something about self destruction about people that are
drinking whiskey first thing in the morning,
that we find them what romantic because we're told all day long to be good and
healthy and sure,
there you go.
There's a puritan,
is it again?
Right.
It's actually a rejection of that.
Oh,
it is,
right.
Yeah.
God,
that is so God damn true.
That's the best way to create sluts.
I'm not slut shaming by the way.
Um,
when I was a kid,
we all knew cath every,
exactly.
I didn't even have to say it.
My first girlfriend was telling me I suck.
Yeah.
I had one too,
which was a freak.
I say bitch,
with all due respect,
it's a nice book.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
I mean this poor girl was so pent up that you would get her alone.
I mean,
I remember I was in the movie theater with her.
I just grabbed her breast and she started heaving and talk
like it was like the world was like,
like Satan was at her door product or,
and they asked for the people work in her eyes.
He was at her door.
Isn't it crazy that that is a direct response to suppression?
This poor girl was so pent up.
The way I described her is like,
if like she had sex with anybody who asked,
like she was so crazy.
It was great and she was beautiful.
But I said that like if you put a dick in front of her,
it was like rolling a ball of yarn in front of a kitten.
Like they couldn't help themselves.
Like this is just some,
something about that.
What they did like surprise,
making it all evil and dark and Catholic school.
They couldn't wait to just get out of that place and run.
Just run to freedom.
Sure.
Yeah.
Just schizophrenia culture we live in.
It's not just Catholics,
right?
It's sort of Americans generally.
I mean,
we're told both things simultaneously all day long.
Sex is bad.
Watch out,
be careful and fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
And here's the big chicken a bikini and you're selling cars.
Horn is a bigger industry than the automobile industry,
but it's terrible.
Right.
But it's terrific.
Goes on there.
It must be secret.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
I remember when it was interesting,
the porn people were asking for a bailout.
It was like sort of a publicity stunt.
But the reality is that like that industry was crippled.
I mean that industry had its legs taken out by the Internet.
I mean,
there was,
there was a guy that used to live in my neighborhood who's a porn producer and
uh,
you know,
he's living high on the hog.
He had like a fat Mercedes lived in his big ass house and they,
his house eventually went up.
It was bankrupt.
It went bankrupt and they fucking,
they sold that bitch.
They took it from him,
closed
on it.
I knew a major porn producer who just died actually recently.
Um,
but he,
um,
he said they were figuring out ways to monetize it and I,
I didn't quite understand it,
but the,
the tube channels and all that stuff,
he said they actually figured out a way to get revenue out of that and I'm not
sure how,
but anyway,
yeah.
Plugging,
stealing people's credit card numbers.
I don't know.
Getting videos of you jacking off to it on those little Webcam.
There you go.
That the FBI's watching.
Yeah.
Let them watch how many they're going to watch a lot since apparently 300
million people.
How many FBI people he got there keeping an eye on people jerk it off.
You're going to go blind.
Fucking people are going to be staring at monitors all day coke bottle glasses
to go to stumble out of that fucking place into the light of day.
I'd rather work in a coal mine and then have that job.
It's similar effects,
I'm sure.
Similar effects.
Good Lord.
Yeah.
What a strange culture.
Now you're,
you're a grown adult with children and a college professor and you're,
you're faced with all these contradictions in this ridiculous way.
We're living our life in the society.
Like how frustrating is it for you to see things so clearly,
but yet see this schizophrenia bizarre society that you're forced to exist in?
I live in hell.
I mean,
yeah.
in a way it's true.
It's like God,
I don't know.
Yeah,
no,
I'm just angry a lot.
Yeah,
seriously.
Yeah.
No,
I'm sort of angry much of the day.
Yeah.
I mean,
reading the news,
reading people's opinions.
I'm reading my colleague's work and seeing what they're doing with 19 year old
girls and even crazier.
It's like,
it's,
it's even in college,
it's ridiculous.
I mean,
it's like humans are fucked,
man.
I'm pissed off.
I,
yeah,
I've been talking to some friends about this.
It's like,
you know,
um,
Socrates said the unexamined life is not worth living.
And actually I'm beginning to think that it's too painful to live,
you know,
I just,
Whoa,
you're fucking deep in this.
I'd rather be ignorant sometimes.
Really Start Trinkets on sometimes.
I used to do that and I gave it up.
Irish Russell partly,
partly enough.
See The freckles Irish enough.
You've got it in your kid.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Do.
Sure do.
So you used to drink to try to avoid reality.
Um,
yeah.
Basically just to mitigate.
Yeah.
It was like an escape.
It was totally an escape.
Do you think there's a certain amount of paying attention to the world that may
perhaps be detrimental to the individual?
Like there's,
there's,
there's a certain,
there's a certain gauntlet.
The all,
we all have to sort of run to live our lives.
Regulations that we have to follow as preposterous as they may be.
But I've often often wondered,
there's like this struggle between trying to think about how much should I just
concentrate on and enjoying my time here.
And being nice to people,
doing what I can to just enjoy my time.
There's your ludicrous,
but there it is.
Yeah.
Or completely getting immersed in all the intricacies of the,
the,
the bullshit.
I don't know.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
I've been an intellectual my whole life.
My family is all intellectual.
It's all we've done is just talk about the world and study the world and talk
about it and talk about it and get,
and most of it is negative,
right?
It's not like,
oh,
it's,
you know,
four of course.
And foreign policy's great,
you know,
um,
and it's painful and it hurts.
And it's like some of,
so much of it is literally about life and death and people dying.
And it's some of that,
some of it.
Um,
man,
I have a hard time recovering from.
So the Michael Brown thing was bad enough in Ferguson.
You know,
I don't know if you saw the video of,
um,
I don't know how you pronounce his name,
but Kajieme Powell,
who was killed about two days later,
he would choose the kid.
He was clearly mentally ill.
He walked up to the cops and he said,
shoot me,
shoot me.
They said he had a butter knife or something in his hand and there's a video of
them just shooting him dead.
I cried all night long and I am still,
that was like what,
two months ago?
I'm still bothered by that,
you know,
and knowing that that's a fairly common thing for a lot of people in this
society,
you know that and if you live in a particular neighborhoods that's like a normal
thing to happen.
Particularly neighborhoods in some ways,
sort of like a microcosm for the issues of the world.
It's very difficult to overcome momentum and the momentum of a terrible
neighborhood,
a crime ridden neighborhoods.
Sure.
Born into poverty and born into the momentum of all these unemployed people on
welfare.
In that case,
it's being born into a state of occupation.
You know,
I think,
I think that there are many of those military state.
It's basically a military occupation.
It is.
God Damn it.
And you know what,
and like the military is militarization of the police is only accentuated it,
but it's been going on for a long time.
That's why black people have it.
Just a very,
very different view of police than white people do.
And it's just something white people have to accept and understand.
And it's hard to,
if you never go to Compton and never see what it's like and you don't get pulled
over for simply driving or walking down the street,
you know?
But God damn,
man,
I just,
I,
when I saw that video,
I was like,
okay,
I'm giving up politics.
I'm just,
I can't do this anymore.
It's too upsetting.
I mean,
stuff like war and stuff like police violence,
when I see video of it or hear about it,
it's just,
it devastates me.
It really does.
And the worst aspects of human beings right in front of you and it's not in your
life,
your life.
You're going where you going?
You're talking to students,
you're doing this thing,
and then you immerse yourself through the internet or whatever the media you're,
you're getting this vision of the worst parts of humans.
There's certain things you know and like the idea of locking people up for
drugs.
Just putting the prisons,
just putting people in prisons for stuff like that for life.
There's people in prison right now for life.
I can't even,
I mean the depth of my feelings about that are just unspeakable.
I mean,
I just want to blow them up.
Yeah.
Now when you talk about not wanting to live though,
do you know,
not wanting to think,
but you said,
I'm wanting to know you didn't want to be a part of it.
You like,
do you mean what you have to know though for what you do for a living?
Right,
exactly.
That's the problem.
That's the conundrum.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
So sometimes I just want to be like a surfer and just smoke weed.
Why do you do that and surf?
Cause you can't make any money on it.
And also I'm not,
I mean like 49 like I can't take it,
but I want it.
Well you couldn't take a surfer,
you body moves while you're moving around.
Normal issues.
Physical issues?
No,
no,
like actually seriously,
I want to know,
I want it to be a kickboxer.
Actually I do,
I train well we tie with Joe Schilling
but is committed as a gym.
The yard.
Yeah.
And everyone should go to the yard.
It's the greatest gym.
Uh,
I tore my ACL there three months ago,
but until then.
Yeah,
six days a week.
And how did you tear your ACL?
Tried to do a flying knee and landed funny.
Oh Man.
I know.
Just hitting pads and stuff.
No,
I was all by myself with a heavy bag and I just didn't know,
did a flying knee.
It just stupid.
It was nothing.
I just,
I know landed,
it's like a lot of ACL is or just that kind of thing.
Right.
Where you just tour mind taking a bag.
Yeah,
toward both of them.
That's what it was kicking a fucking heavy bag.
Well actually got loosened up and guy kicked me in the side.
I'm bad at checking leg kicks.
Oh.
So he kicked me up.
It loosens like a week before that.
And then this thing,
I think that's what happened.
But yeah,
no,
I was like,
I wish I could just do this.
Really?
Oh yes.
That's why I love the new intellectual though.
Aren't you aware of the negative impact?
You mean the whole brain damage?
I know,
no,
that's the whole thing.
And it's such a bummer and like I'm just,
I know.
But you spar.
Yeah.
And if you notice any difference?
Well,
no,
but I've just been more and more worried about it.
Right.
It's like I'm just constantly worried about it and that's the problem.
It's,
and now I don't know what to do.
Like I'm,
I'm 40 fucking nine and I'm like going in there and they want me to fight.
They want you to fight.
They've asked me to fight really like an amateur bow.
Like a smoker too.
So they can get press.
No,
just cause that's what they do because that's what they train fighters,
train fire fighters.
Yeah.
It's one of the big Moitai gyms in California.
So yeah,
so smokers or you know,
there's whatever.
So you're training and they're like,
listen,
take this to the next place.
Joe's trainer who owns the gym with Mark Tomorrow,
he said,
hey,
we should get you a fight.
And I like laughed at him.
I was like,
come on man,
I'm 40 fucking,
I mean the guys,
they're all like 25 year old ripped Korean dudes and stuff.
And I um,
my friend Steve is almost 60 and uh,
he's been my friend,
he's been my friend since we were,
I was 15 when I met him and he was an air force flight surgeon and he was doing
his residency for ophthalmology is just a wild man.
He's always been doing something and he's a doctor now in Arizona,
but he's the reason why I became a standup comedian cause he talked me into
doing it when I was young and I was fighting.
My point being this guy to this day is ready to take a fight.
16 he's closing,
closing in on 60 he'll take a fight tomorrow.
He's got,
his problem is he was on the u s ski team.
He's a mad man and he had at least 10 operations on his knees.
Both of his knees looked like like a fish that you filleted and then stitched
back together again because they had,
he had his knees done in the 80s when they would take your hamstring,
they were,
the way they would reconstruct her ACL was they'd use your hamstring so they
would cut you open like a big line on the side.
Like I'm sure they did yours probably.
Did they do a piece of gum surgery yet?
You haven't?
No.
No,
no.
It's not that bad.
I mean they tell me it's not that bad.
Yeah.
And he did an MRI when the MRI partial partial.
How much?
They didn't tell me.
They didn't know.
Why didn't they tell you?
I don't know.
Where'd you go?
Kaiser.
Okay.
That's no good.
Yeah.
We'll talk afterwards with a real doctor.
Not,
I'm not a real doctor,
but I've talked to the dealer or doctor.
Yeah.
That's what I needed.
And general practitioners are just knocking.
He's an Orthopedist,
but even an orthopedist who doesn't deal with real athletes is going to say,
oh,
you're okay.
Just walk around and not going to be fine.
That means you got a bum knee for the rest of your life that's ready to give
out.
Not Shit.
Depending upon how much of a partial tear.
Yeah.
I mean,
if it's 10% tear,
yeah,
let it rehab.
I got no percentage from them.
Yeah.
You need to know.
Okay.
And you needed a guy who's an expert at reading Mris.
I've had two different Mris done in my back.
One of them that was shit,
and one of them that was really clear and it was much different results.
I'm dying,
man.
I've got to get back in there because as I was saying,
like when I'm in the gym,
you know,
as you know you,
that's all you think about,
right.
Everything else goes away.
Isis has gone foreign policy,
history's gone,
blah,
academia.
Fuck,
that Shit's all gone.
I'm just thinking about that,
that fist coming at my face.
Right.
Or even if I'm just working on the bag,
it's just beautiful and I just,
I wish I just often wish I could just do that.
Or like I want to move to Thailand and do that thing.
Right.
Really go to Pooh cat.
Oh my God.
And just live there on whatever it is and all in mark did that day.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
I know he's a financial advisor and he went to Thailand.
He lived there for a month and belonged to one of those gyms.
Changed my last name to fair tax or whatever.
Damn man.
You got it bad,
Huh?
Well,
your kickboxing for you had this idea.
I started with boxing just like bullshit.
Well I took a,
I took some classes at church,
uh,
Church street gym in New York when I lived there and then that was like 10 years
ago and then,
but not seriously.
And then I did like bullshit cardio kick.
Then I joined the yard about two years ago and then I just got really into it.
I want to start when I start at the yard.
It was like that's all I wanted to do and it's all I was thinking about,
dude.
So I am the only phd history professor in this country.
I am sure who has listened to you call 500 fights.
Wow.
Yeah.
No,
I've watched like probably a majority of the UFC fights.
I've watched every single glory fight of watch k one.
Yeah,
that's it.
I got obsessed with it about two years ago.
Sucks it,
it gives you praying damage.
It doesn't,
it doesn't,
it.
We need to fix this.
Listen man,
when I,
it's one of the main reasons that I got in.
Do you feel like comedy,
do you feel like you got any Oh yeah,
I've definitely pretty late.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean I talk,
okay.
I was going to say your brain is doing pretty well for a guy who didn't graduate
college.
I mean,
I am fairly articulate.
Um,
but I definitely
been hit in the head a lot.
Yeah.
You know,
but it was all done by the time I was in my early twenties.
Okay.
I stopped,
but I was worried I'd get headaches.
I'd lay in bed after sparring,
I get headaches,
but I was sparring with some murders.
I've only done kind of moderate sparrings and I haven't really gotten hit hard
while I was fighting two.
I've fought.
Yeah,
that's a different story a lot.
It's like window tournament's in three kickboxing bouts,
but the,
um,
the sparring is the more dangerous thing.
I know.
Because you'd get concussed and then guys would dust you off and push it right
back in there.
Right.
Especially back then when I was doing it was the late eighties that nobody knew
what the fuck is going on with the brain.
There was no real studies done.
They knew when people were punched drunk,
but they didn't really have a good grasp on traumatic brain injury.
Right.
I have a good friend who's a doctor and his specialty is traumatic brain injury
and he has enlightened me in a way that's absolutely terrifying.
He's like,
you know,
you could go waterboarding,
like not water boarding,
jet skiing,
curb like a,
what is it when they pull you behind a boat and you're fucking bouncing around?
Water skiing,
water skiing.
Yeah.
He's like,
guys get brain damage from water skiing.
no doubt about it.
She's like,
the pituitary gland is very sensitive and it's when it gets jostled around and
banged up depending upon the individual look,
there's people that box and they're fine.
And then there's people that they get hit a few times and then they have all
sorts of depression issues.
Their body stops producing hormones properly.
See,
I dunno,
man.
Traumatic brain injury is no fucking joke.
And I have had the unfortunate experience of knowing people pre and post.
I are good friends.
I'm sure you did it.
I knew that that when they started out they were fine and now they're not fun.
Yeah.
Can I,
this is a question I can't believe I got this opportunity to ask Joe Rogan this.
Do you,
are there UFC fighters or former UFC fighters that you're sure have it
unquestioned?
Okay.
Without a doubt.
Yeah.
No doubt about it.
Like many without a doubt.
Okay.
Yeah.
If you stay in there long enough,
it gets you like you can see it and some of them.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
It's in the same thing.
I can think of a couple who are leading suspects.
I would be a real piece of shit if I denied it.
It's uh,
I mean there's a lot of people,
I'm sure they would like me to not comment on it,
but it's one of my only issues with,
I don't mind broken bones.
Like I see like when Anderson silver broke his leg,
it was nasty,
but I got to,
oh,
that's nothing.
Yeah,
I'll trade that for bringing injury any day.
I was way more concerned when he got knocked unconscious course when he got
knocked out.
And then when he came back just a few months later,
I was the one guy that was saying he's not going to be the same.
Like you gotta be aware like that is,
that's a guy that got knocked unconscious for months ago.
He's not going to be the same.
He's in training already.
He's sparring already.
He's not gonna be the same guy six months later.
He's just not,
there's no way around it.
It's one of the beautiful things that,
that um,
Manny Pacquiao was Treanor um,
Freddy Roach has got trauma related Parkinson's himself.
So when he got knocked out by Marquez,
Freddie Roach was like,
you're not fighting for a year.
Like you just need to recover.
I'm like,
just get that in your head now.
You want to keep going.
You're not fighting for a year.
It's such a bummer.
It's a unit and unboxings the worst.
Clearly.
I don't know about that man.
I used to say the established,
I used to think that too,
but the reality is it's all about the training and in training,
MMA fighters are getting hit in the head a lot.
I mean,
you're not getting hit in the head as much unless you're a guy who only wants to
stand up.
And then you're also dealing with kicks and kicks are a different animal.
You can kick so much harder you up,
then you can punch getting kicked in the head.
You can probably kick 10 times harder than American punch course.
You know,
I can send a heavybag flying across the room with a kitchen.
And if you imagine what that can do to your fucking head,
it's terrible.
I've seen guys get hit in the head in kickboxing matches and they're never the
same again.
Oh,
I've seen it.
I've seen it with my own eyes.
So that's,
that's something to think about.
Go to the ground.
Yeah.
Learned some Jujitsu.
Danieli Bolelli my good friend.
I love that dude mutual friend.
Yeah,
I love that.
We're probably going to start,
that's the move.
That's the intellectual pursuit because it's,
first of all,
it's far more complex.
Realize far less on athleticism.
And you can do it deep into your old age,
right?
You know,
Helio Gracie was doing it and it's fucking eighties you know,
it's chess.
Yeah.
And as long as you do it with good partners,
you can,
you can really go at it and be aware that the guy's not going to hurt you.
You know,
things happen accidentally.
Needs get twisted and you know,
you fall funny,
but no head injury,
no manager,
very rarely you know me.
You can collide heads occasionally,
but it's not the goal,
you know,
and getting choked unconscious really has no repercussions.
No big deal.
You just go,
you wake up and you can actually guys do it all the time.
They get choked out and they go back to rolling like moments later.
Right.
Get you involved.
I'll get you in there.
I'm going to get you a good doctor too.
All right,
good.
Thank you very much for doing this man.
It was a lot of fun.
We really,
really enjoyed it.
It was just three hours,
just blue box.
That's it.
And A,
your book renegade history of the United States.
Uh,
it's available right now.
You can get it on Amazon.
Is it an audio book as well?
Audio of you reading it?
Nope.
It's a Shakespearian actor.
Why did they do that?
Did they,
did they resist you reading it?
You'd be perfect.
It's hilarious.
He does like black,
like slave dialect in a Shakespearian sonnet.
The Shakespearian read it,
but it's still good.
You're still buy it.
I,
yes.
Everyone by it.
By that and by the book and uh,
fattiest Russell,
you could find them on Twitter.
And what is your website?
Thaddeus russell.com that's it.
Thank you sir.
Appreciate it.
Thank you very enjoyable.
And I have to Piss so bad,
like.